there have been incredible film
adaptations of TV shows and vice versa
there have even been Stellar
reimaginings of popular books for the
young and old alike onto the small and
silver screens and despite some Book
Lovers lamenting the depiction of a
certain event or the omission of a
particular scene I think it's safe to
say that in the right hands a film or TV
show based on a book cannot only be done
effectively but brilliantly so why is it
so difficult to adapt a video game into
live action well it actually has nothing
to do with the complexity of the plots
these games boast or the quirky ideas
they often explore it doesn't even
necessarily have to do with the team
producing the recreation though that is
important in some instances instead
quite simply what makes this endeavor so
hard has everything to do with what sets
video games as an entertainment medium
apart from any other form of media and
that secret ingredient is active
engagement and the active engagement
element of a video game playing
experience offers a gargantuan
difference to to what tv offers on a
foundational fundamental level which
cannot be overlooked in the case of
HBO's admittedly ambitious adaptation of
one of the best games of all time the
last of us being an active participant
in a story rather than an onlooker has
the knock-on effect of boosting the
stakes of every scene the tension of
every encounter and your own sense of
personal investment as a player in the
story and this is why adapting video
games into live action has been
historically cursed with troubled
releases unlike when a book is adapted
when adapting a video game a director
cannot simply rely on the source
material entirely because unlike books
which connect key scenes and story beats
through narrative the connective tissue
offered by a video game is active
gameplay and in the case of naughty dog
the connective tissue of a great video
game is integrating that story Into the
active gameplay experience itself which
creates an exciting problem that The
Last of Us HBO series needs to solve how
do they replace the gameplay sections
with meaningful additions that make up
for the lack of active participation and
to answer this question I want to take a
walk through each and every one of these
Nine episodes in this series observe
what they've changed what they've added
and analyzed the merits of these
decisions and how they impact the Merit
of the story with respect to the source
material itself The Last of Us is my
favorite video game of all time and
needless to say I was extremely curious
to see how they attempted to solve one
of the most persistent problems plaguing
the video game industry how to translate
the active magic of a video game
experience into the passive but
captivating medium of Television I'm
Tony nutmark and this is my review of
HBO's The Last of Us
in the intro I mentioned that a director
cannot simply rely on the source
material to create a worthy adaptation
simply stitching together cutscenes and
calling it a day just won't cut it as
seen in many YouTube videos that trident
failed to do just that you might get a
rough idea of the story at hand but
something foundational will be missing
the secret ingredient the active
engagement the superb gameplay that
transports you the player from point A
in the story to point B and that now
requires new story sections to be
written from scratch that otherwise
never existed prior scenes that need to
replace active gameplay experiences
without losing the spirit of the game
and story itself which means of course
one thing changes are not only going to
be made when translating this Game's
plot but those changes are also
imminently necessary and any change
however slide will certainly be noticed
and would certainly risk corrupting the
spirit of the original experience if
handled poorly and so changes need to be
made of course but they need to be
correct choices that ring true to the
original story that don't get in the way
of our personal enjoyment and
expectations and if possible enhance
parts of the story in ways that the game
simply could not and so you can imagine
my joy when it was announced that Neil
druckman the original Creator and writer
of the original story of The Last of Us
would be one of the two directors
helming the production and creative
process in my opinion that was a
necessary and important first decision
you need look no further than the
shambles of an adaptation that was
Dragon Ball Evolution with the powers
that be actively ignoring the
suggestions and advice of Akira Toriyama
himself the creator of Dragon Ball
directly and even for the live-action
adaptation of Cowboy Bebop Watanabe
wasn't even involved in the slightest
and naturally as a result of this
creative negligence both Akira Toriyama
and Watanabe themselves were both left
with their hands hanging standing in awe
of the messes these Studios made using
their stories and these were adaptations
of TV shows to film not video games
which as we discussed offers so many
more hurdles to clear but a successful
Creator in one field isn't necessarily
equipped to succeed in another adjacent
field and so after some failed attempts
at bringing the last of us to live
action and film drochman finally found
the perfect partner many years later in
Chernobyl Creator Craig Mason and once
aboard the seeds of a premium HBO series
were finally planted these directors
were hungry ambitious afforded an
enormous budget of no less than a
hundred million dollars but what truly
set my expectations for this production
was The Guiding philosophy they followed
in producing this series and that
guiding philosophy was if we change
something it has to be an improvement it
cannot take anything away
and there are no treatments for this no
preventatives no cures they don't exist
it's not even possible to make them
so if that happens
we lose
we'll be back
this is it I'm not kidding when I say
that every ounce of trepidation I felt
going into this series immediately
evaporated when I saw this entirely new
and phenomenally scripted directed and
performed scene I love John Hannah at
the best of times but the way this
setting acts as a natural and compelling
form of exposition to initiate the
uninitiated on the fungal infection that
will eventually take over the world is
breathtaking in every sense of the word
and once again encouraged me that the
approach taken with this series was
going to be one of adaptation and not
exact Recreation beat for beat and
despite this scene taking place in the
1960s it managed to feel relevant to
even the modern day mentioning how viral
pandemics are bad but curable while
fungal ones are almost impossible to
contain let alone cure due to their
devastating adaptable Natures the
opposition to Hannah's concerns calls it
unlikely due to fungi needing a high
temperature to thrive in leading Hannah
to retort by touching on possibility of
global warming bringing it back home to
us as viewers again it's doing that very
real thing of we know something bad is
happening but we're doing nothing about
it it is a perfect real world parallel
in my opinion and amazingly this scene
itself was almost left on The Cutting
Room floor the initial idea for the
scene was Pitch to drop in by Mason
himself but Neil thought it felt strange
instead opting for a more
straightforward and clinical docu style
opening akin to the famous David
Attenborough segment on quarter sips
fungus thankfully however once they were
nearing the conclusion of their
production both of them came to realize
that this would have made for quite a
boring opening and with newly found
motivation and vigor Mason overhauled
his talk show segment once again to
something both directors were happy with
and that's what we see today and it's
just as well things got off to a great
start because it's one thing to create
faithful new material and it's an
entirely different process to
repurposing gameplay and wouldn't you
know it this next section deals with
exactly that
did you what I don't hear anything
this is one of the rare instances you'll
hear me say this but what druckman and
Mason did here with Sarah was perfect
there's an argument that the choices
made in writing Sarah hair could be
better than that offered by the game
itself and I think that was made
possible partially due to the type of
game The Last of Us is unlike RPGs or
role-playing games where the players
themselves are actual characters in the
game I think it's important to
understand that that is specifically not
what the last of us is in The Last of Us
in the story you aren't Joel you're not
even Sarah as you navigate their dark
home on the night of the outbreak you
control them but only to a point you
can't make Sarah make a call the script
doesn't account for you can't make her
run out the door now this limited and
curated control of the character in this
game offers a layer of intensity and
immersion certainly but it's important
to remember that it's not your story you
aren't making choices as these
characters this is an experience where
you personally follow the lives of these
characters through their eyes and during
gameplay sections control how they
arrive from point A to point B but
unlike more open less linear games you
must always arrive at point B within the
last of us when you're in control of
Sarah you can choose whether or not to
engage with the environment of the house
but you will always need to arrive at
the patio doors where Joel runs in
distressed it is a fixed story that you
know needs to play out a specific way
and this my friends is called meta
engagement now it of course means that
this game can at times challenge you to
do things you otherwise may not want to
do as an individual and on its face that
might sound bad but in actuality it's
part of the reason why the ending to the
first game was effective as It
ultimately became adding yet another
layer of complexity for the team at HBO
to overcome and in addition to that one
of the most interesting aspects of the
first game I thought was the choice to
have us control Sarah in the very first
section and not Joel but of course this
was for a good reason a massive strength
the game possesses is the ability to
bond us to the characters we control
through through shared experience unlike
on TV in this level we wake up as Sarah
and feel her isolation and Dread as it
becomes increasingly obvious that
something serious is about to happen
she's completely and utterly alone
defenseless and the best part is that
the game tailors the levels pacing to
our individual sensibilities if you want
you can raise ahead to Joel running in
through the patio doors triggering the
next section but if you're someone that
wants to bask in the atmosphere for a
little bit longer there's plenty to
explore and investigate whether it be on
Joe's TV the explosion outside or the
missed calls on the phone in the kitchen
to name but a few this is all to say
that right out the gate the HBO series
was tasked with overcoming a first level
that profoundly bonded us to the
character of Sarah and by association
Joe so how do they approach this first
challenge the answer quite cleverly I
think right off the bat there was a
conscious choice to age up Sarah from 12
to 14 years old this is a small but I
think significant difference this
introductory scene establishes there are
not as a helpless child but as a
responsible teen she knocks on Joe's
door in the morning to wake him up she
makes both his and her breakfast she
doesn't have to be told to do her
homework and even manages to point out
that Joel's shirt was on inside out
before he goes off to work this all
pains Sarah as caring responsible and
intelligent but more than that bonds us
to the character immediately she's just
a wonderful person and in addition to
that in just two minutes we understand
Joel and Sarah's relationship Sarah is
Joel's Rock and while it's left as
simply subtext once Sarah presents Joel
with his watch fixed she says you
weren't going to do it yourself and the
face Jewel makes following that remark
is short-lived but it's grief stricken
suddenly Sarah's characterization makes
sense suddenly it makes sense why she's
Joel's Rock the one who takes care of
things he isn't good at because she's
adopted the responsibilities of her late
mother she's half Joel's age but she
knows him better than he knows himself
and it's that aspect of our character
that's revealed to us as we follow her
throughout her day to not only Bond us
to the character profoundly but also
offers plenty of subtle hints to let us
know that not all is well in this world
as she goes about her day little things
like the police the news broadcasts that
cause concern amongst the watchmakers
she sought out or even the jets flying
overhead All of This lends to this sense
of rising tension that is all over this
introductory portion we're anticipating
something big and boy do we get just
that there are three pillars that Define
The Last of Us for me action adventure
drama and survival horror you can't
deliver a great adaptation of this
series without all three and I'm happy
to report that this episode absolutely
Nails the survival horror element of
this game's adaptation making Sarah
older and more self-assured meant that
the approach they took with the game
with Sarah exploring the house wouldn't
achieve the same level of Terror this is
why their neighbors become much more
established characters acting as a
vehicle to give the neighborhood some
color establish a community and it lays
the seeds for some reveals later on but
of course sets up another major
deviation from the main game
[Music]
this is
all right this is scary no matter who
you are and between her being chased out
of the house Tommy and Joel arriving to
save her or their quick getaway all of
this is enhanced by the subtle
Exposition offered in this episode's
opening half and before we move on I
just want to talk for a moment about the
change in design to those that become
infected and while purists might want
the infected to behave exactly like they
did in the games the film critic in me
cannot disagree more as many of you
might already know the infect in The
Last of Us game spread the fungal
infection slightly differently in some
cases and in others very differently to
how they infect people in the TV show
and I think creatively there were some
amazing changes implemented here some of
which don't come into effect until
episode 2 but I'm going to talk about it
all here from a visual standpoint the
biting zombie Trope has been done to
death and visually we all know what to
expect almost 200 episodes of The
Walking Dead exist for God's sake and
demonstrate the undead eating people in
more ways than anyone could possibly
imagine Neil druckman in fact bans the
use of the word zombie from being being
used in the production of the games and
so it's only natural he'd be open to
further divorcing his version of the
undead to the more commonly seen
variants grotesque tendrils reaching
from the mouth of the infected like a
creature exiting the host to impregnate
the minds of their victims with these
monstrous qualities visually this is
incredibly striking disgusting and
terrifying all at the same time and it's
not even the best mechanical change this
Series has given to the infected either
nope and that I will talk about when
it's revealed in the story later on and
while HBO is The Last of Us often
demonstrates that it's not afraid to
make necessary changes I'd be lying if I
said that I didn't jump out of my seat
or become transfixed on my television
set when certain significant moments
from the game reared their heads
eventually the transit scene from their
home into the town is shot almost
identically like the video game's
depiction of events only once again
they've given Sarah more to say and to
be concerned about the dynamic in the
car is fascinating Sarah genuinely
piecing together reason after reason to
be concerned about their own infected
status and Joel acting very much like
the Father Figure trying to dissuade any
concerns and Tommy follows everything
his big brother is saying despite his
own personal feelings of the matter this
further speaks to the relationship they
have and the Unseen Journey they go on
together over the next 20 years the
Frantic nature of the cinematography as
the trio tried to navigate their Town
amidst this frenzied Panic is something
else an incredibly well orchestrated if
there's one thing I want to give this
production credit for it's their
dedication to trying to do as much as
they can with practical effects the fire
the infected flooding out of the theater
even the car crashes that eventually
separate them and despite there being a
decent amount of computer-generated
effects also like the newly added plane
crash the chase that ensues between an
infected Runner and Joel carrying his
daughter is some Next Level commitment
on behalf of the actor playing the
runner the way he smashes through doors
chairs and a host of other objects only
further sells how doomed Joel and Sarah
are until
truth be told there are a handful of
scenes I was worried for in this
adaptation and this one was right up
there on the list this scene might be my
favorite in the entire game in terms of
how it evokes such intense emotion from
me and from the outset I knew that
recapturing that lightning in a bottle
was not only going to be difficult but
even trying to do so would be more
difficult than the initial shot in many
ways because it's going up against such
a strong performance we're all now
intimately familiar with and while I can
speak for everyone watching
from my perspective I think they knocked
it out of the park back when they shot
this for the game druckman was very
clear with Troy Baker that he needed to
stop acting he was too focused on giving
his own emotional performance instead of
focusing on the sequence of emotion Joel
is going through he conveyed to Baker
that this needs to begin with confusion
and denial and attempt to save her and
then the reality setting in that she's
unsavable and eventually gone the show
manages to capture this perfectly right
down to Sarah's animal-like whimpers as
she Fades away forever Joel clutching at
the single most important person in his
life unable to let her go just yet and
just like the game this scene it
destroyed me
foreign
that's super dark but there's actually
an interesting story surrounding this
part of the first episode and while we
are only halfway through originally
episode 1 ended right here would you
believe with the last shot being where
Joel throws that kid into the fire pit
this being symbolic of how his Humanity
has long since been lost and how he has
fundamentally changed the person since
we last saw him that any hint of
sentimentality or fragility has been
hidden beneath years of denial trauma
and resentment towards the world
following his daughter's death but
ultimately the decision was made to
combine the first and second episode
together into one and narratively I
think they made the right decision and
to be perfectly honest despite having
sung the Praises of the first part of
this episode for the entire runtime of
this video so far even I have to admit
that ending the premiere episode here
would have been an utter disaster and
ironically enough we have the network to
thank for this change according to the
directors Ace Espio didn't think there
was a sufficient hook with this ending
and furthermore back-to-back child
deaths might in a way give the people
who are watching for the first time the
wrong impression about the show's
messaging the story of The Last of Us
does deal with a lot of heavy themes but
the general overarching narrative sees
two unlikely companions help each other
on a trip across a very dangerous
America on a mission and with that being
the conclusion to what was then the
first episode the goal hadn't been
established there were no motivations
established and like HBO said there was
no book naturally they totally agreed
and that's why they ended up adding The
Original Episode 2 into the mix an
episode that gives us everything that
was missing and so so much more
including that all-important goal let me
out are you gonna hey [__]
[Applause]
the introduction to Ellie here adds a
nice new bit of texture surprisingly
with the benefit of going back to the
story already told the team managed to
add elements from the American Dreams
comic that elaborated on Marlene's
relationship with Ellie and her early
years two elements that I returned to
later on in the series in a major way
also but in addition to that it
introduces the fireflies with great
clarity showcasing their goals their
crumbling organization and further
insight into Marlene as a character the
fireflies were always quite an unknown
entity for much of the first game
despite their importance so I think
these additions actually do wonders for
onboarding audiences into the world and
its politics however with these
additions come convergence of storylines
and as a fan of the games going in I
knew Robert's section being a fairly
lengthy tutorial for the game's combat
system would need some significant
overhauls in order to be adapted
effectively in the game the scanners and
ruthlessness of the quarantine Zone were
shown to us as a background element as
you walk through the streets you see
people lined up and being scanned and
before they're shot dead in broad
daylight it's a very Savage dystopian
and immersion Driving Experience however
quite evidently these artifacts of the
game's atmosphere weren't used in
comparable fashion for the TV show
speaking on this change Mason and
druckman said that violence in the game
is very different from violence on a TV
screen with how many enemies you mow
down in a game moments like these feel
less intense and work well in this
context while on screen they're more
real and have a very different and
perhaps more extreme effect that would
hit too hard for what was actually
intended by taking this approach they
managed to create a visual parallel with
Joel holding a child's body and also
convey the ruthlessness without being so
in your face about it further emphasize
with the public hangings later on it's
all still horrifying but it's not quite
as absurd as public firing squads
executing in the streets while people
don't bat an eye and like I alluded to
earlier in this video the rest of the
episode is largely entirely overhauled
from how the game plays out despite
using this same story beats while Tess
Robert Joel and even Ellie are all
introduced differently the core of the
story being told is very much still
there Robert is still terrified of Jolin
Tess he's double crossed them and they
are trying to get back what they're owed
from him in addition to that they've
done something I wish the games did more
of and that's totally the character of
Tommy into the early story section in
the games Joel resorts to reaching out
to Tommy when he needs help but in this
retelling Tommy is in suspected trouble
and Joel is trying to gather the
necessary funds to reach out to him and
save him and efficiently this newly
crafted Recreation manages to weave in
the dwindling Firefly storyline with
Ellie so damn naturally also I swear as
a story I prefer this version of events
which I mean I should given that the TV
show's specialty is storytelling I mean
so much time in the game's mandatory
Combat tutorial is spent with Joel
trying to get some guns that Robert
stole and as a player I never really
cared about those guns I never cared
about that mission but this has helped
massively in the series by replacing
those guns with a car battery a car
battery that we know Joel once so he can
try to help his little brother whom we
are already connected with it's just so
so much better and I think it's a shame
that this part of the episode is likely
getting slept on compared to the
action-packed first half with the
initial outbreak and the child murder
but the sheer amount of creative heavy
lifting that's been carried out here to
make this section not only work
narratively but to thrive and in my
opinion surpass the original in some
respects cannot be understated keeping
folks akame on the Forefront of our
minds introducing and establishing alien
aspects of her past earlier than normal
and of course bringing up Bill and Frank
much earlier also planting seeds for the
future but one of the more significant
changes that didn't need to necessarily
be there but was changed anyway was this
explain you better explain fast
three weeks old you know everyone turns
within 2
days stop bullshitting it's three weeks
I swear
after Joel and Tess accept the job of
transporting Ellie to the Capitol
Building there's our first reveal as
players that Ellie isn't any Ordinary
Girl the emphasis on the scene is
squarely on her situation this reveal
and why they will be moving forward it's
very much rooted in the turmoil of the
world so to speak and it's also a
wonderful moment to show how resourceful
Ellie is as a character however the HBO
version of events has a similar approach
but with a very very different Focus
while Ellie's resourcefulness is present
and she's revealed to have been infected
technically the reveal is very much a
background element which on one hand
makes sense as it is largely hinted to
if not outright confirmed while she was
tied up by the fireflies instead the
focus of this scene comes through Joel
as he comes face to face with his demon
and general PTSD concerning the event
that took place with Sarah 20 years ago
there's a wonderful shot that mirrors
his tragic past moments before the
Soldier's trigger is pulled Joel pulls
his trigger and unloads a series of
Savage and brutal attacks of end less
clubbing blows to the Federal Officer
and what I found to be the most
interesting about this wasn't
necessarily Joel's actions but in fact
what's happening in the background
Ellie's reaction there's a contrast here
with Joel and his past self obviously
the camera switches between those two
moments to draw attention to that fact
exactly but there's I think a more
profound comparison being made that
wasn't apparent in the game and that is
between Ellie and Sarah there are two
moments from the beginning of this
episode I'd like to draw your attention
to the first being Sarah's inspection of
a particular knife in Joel's drawer
putting it back before going about her
day and the second being her reaction to
Joel killing the old infected neighbor
as she chases Sarah out of her house
these are seemingly two innocuous scenes
that might not have anything to do with
each other until you realize that
another significant difference between
this shot of Joel and this shot of Joel
is that he isn't holding any injured
person and why you might be asking well
Ellie kept her knife with her and what's
more is unlike Sarah who could deal with
the brutality Joel administered on his
neighbor for her own good Ellie not only
can deal with it but examines the
actions almost as if she admires his
ability the contrast being made here
between Joel and his passive is great
but I think there's a more fascinating
contrast being made between Ellie and
Sarah here that I think people need to
talk about but I think for episode 1
this is a good place to launch from and
with the sounds of clickers echoing in
the distance as the camera pulls up
towards the famous Fallen Towers we come
to the close of an utterly fantastic
first episode and the best part is it's
not even the best episode not even close
much the same as the last episode this
one opens with a flashback this time to
outbreak day in Jakarta Indonesia in the
first episode Joel Tommy and Sarah were
discussing where Jakarta might have been
and this cold open flashback concerned
itself with the very event that report
on the radio was covering and I think my
favorite aspect of this short opening
comes from how it elevates the material
in episode 1 retroactively very quickly
it's established that the source of the
outbreak comes from a flower and grain
Factory on its own it's a rather
innocuous Revelation however when you
look back at episode 1 you come to
realize just how close Joel and Sarah
came to becoming infected from the very
food that they would normally consume
Sarah wakes up and complains that
there's no flour for the pancakes close
call number one nobody ate the
neighbor's biscuits when they were
initially offered that's close call
number two Sarah avoids the raisin
cookies after school close call number
three and Joel forgets to get the
birthday cake on his way back from work
close call number four all of these near
misses could have easily led to their
infection and explains exactly why the
neighbors and so much more of the
surrounding population got infected when
few others didn't it's a brilliant
Revelation in my opinion and one that
sits in the background until almost
outright confirmation and this is the
first episode directed by Neil druckman
himself the original director and writer
of the game itself I think with the
sheer number of impressive Easter eggs
and one-to-one game moments in this
episode you could probably guess without
even looking it up but the transition
from game director to live action
director wasn't quite so simple despite
directing actors prior on a mocap stage
druckman mentioned that directing a film
or episode of Live Action television
required a very different approach than
that which he was used to with video
games specifically with regards to the
type of planning required with video
game motion capture while it's still
important to get a good performance you
don't have to think about anything else
necessarily nine times out of ten the 3D
capture data is there so aspects like
camera angles my nude expressions
precise movements and lighting can be
decided upon at a much later date if
need be even if the actors aren't there
themselves with live action however
drachmann had to be very conscious that
what you get on camera barring any VFX
work is final and that was an
interesting new challenge for him
overall I think the episode itself has
really solid Direction particularly when
you take into consideration that he's a
first timer in this field and while I
wouldn't say it's as polished as episode
1 and some of that shaky cam is still
looking a little bit too amateur it does
have some fantastic visual storytelling
and framing in the first scene once we
return to the present day the scene in
question concerns Ellie waking up to two
disgruntled and scared smugglers in Joel
and Tess and really this is a pivotal
moment in the greater story as it's the
first time Ellie's immunity is explored
in a meaningful fashion but it's the
framing of this interaction between the
two parties that I want to draw
attention to here personally in the
games between Tess and Joel Tess is the
one to First latch onto hope and trust
in Ellie's Revelation and beguing Joel
acquiesces to her conviction in this
child and the TV show is the exact same
but presents this I think in a much more
interesting way the scene itself starts
with Ellie sitting eating her sandwich
on a bed of green growing in a pool of
light while Joel and Tess still scared
of what Ellie could be remain off to the
side in the shadows with their guards
still up it doesn't take a genius to
figure out that the light in this scene
represents hope for the future and the
Darkness is the pessimistic reality they
all share right now bringing characters
together into the same frame or even
closer together visually is a great tool
to convey what a director or writer
wants you to feel in a given scene take
that famous panning shot from Goodwill
Hunting For example it's one of my
favorites the scene concerns Sean Will's
therapist played by Robin Williams
delivering an uninterrupted five-minute
monologue where he tries to reach the
troubled young man of Will Hunting
played by Matthew Damon the performance
here is fantastic but it's the framing I
want you to take notice of as Sean is
speaking too will the camera remains
fixed on Sean however as he continues to
speak slowly the camera pans until will
is now sharing the screen with Sean
narratively the text is implying that
Sean is reaching well but visually also
it's clear that these two are now on the
same page as they share the same screen
space as a similar approach in principle
takes place here in this scene with LA
test and Joel respectively when the
conversation or rather negotiation
begins Ellie is firmly on one side
fighting her Corner trying to convince
the other two pictures on the opposite
side of the screen shrouded in darkness
that she needs to get to the Capitol
Building because she is the real deal
however as the conversation continues
Tess slowly emerges from the Shadows
visually moving closer to the hopeful
light that Ellie represents but Joel
someone who has long since lost all hope
refuses to budge Resolute in his
pessimism both sides argue with Tess
who's now standing in the middle of this
argument Ellie wants to March forward
Joel wants to cut their losses and go
back and just like the games Tess
chooses hope and just about manages to
convince Joel to see this through to at
least the Capitol building it's a simple
scene with a simple objective but I just
love the visual idea behind this back
and forth the way it's shot performed
and lit it all screams attention to
detail with a Clear Vision of what this
scene represents you can find this
thoughtful staging all across the
episode 2 by the way as they walk across
the highway Joel hangs back and is
completely detached from Tess and
Ellie's conversation the awkward
face-to-face chat between Ellie and Joel
is Tess is busy unblocking a door
there's a real emphasis on
characterizing everyone through their
placement within a given scene and
that's not to mention all the Care and
framing that so authentically to the
game itself
[Music]
there are some noteworthy deviations
from The Source material in this episode
however most obviously the lack of
spores in the game spores are a threat
but the show does away with this in
favor of a brand new mechanic the fungus
can communicate over long distances
through these fungal root systems Stefan
tendrils in one area and miles away a
horde may hear you and come frantically
searching for you it's gross it's scary
and it adds another wonderful layer to
the possible interactions in this story
that the spores otherwise could provide
Craig Mason mentioned this change came
about due to concerns that while spores
might be a cool idea for a game in the
real world spores don't really operate
like that they don't stay in one place
like they do in the games and so he
didn't think it would sell well for
television and hilariously drockman once
he heard the pitch about the long-range
fungal communication he got all sorts of
mad because he even admitted it would
have been such a great idea that could
have worked super well as a game
mechanic and while we're on the topic of
spores and their ultimate removal here
this is just my take but I would have
imagined having to deal with gas masks
would have been a very annoying part of
production not just for audio but also
for being able to capture powerful
expressions in terrifying situations as
a creative Choice I'm honestly satisfied
that spores don't play a role and are
instead replaced by a much more engaging
narrative mechanic in the root systems
foreign
so this segment is the part that really
defines this episode when people think
about episode 2 they think clickers as
they should they are my favorite enemy
to fight in the series Bar None and
what's interesting about their inclusion
here is that it reveals the first major
series of changes to the timeline of
events in the series in this episode the
show speeds through a lot of gameplay
you don't go through the tall high-rise
building or travel through the subway
station they do however acknowledge the
high-rise collapse in front of them
where Tess refers to it as the weird
[__] dead way but outside of that a
lot of what was once gameplay has been
cut meaning our first encounter with
clickers has been moved to the museum
section and ban is this everything I
wanted and more from the clickers in
this series the way this scene captures
The Dread and Terror of the clickers is
nothing short of perfection everything
from the Practical effects used to bring
them to life to the actors convincing
movements to the out of focus
introduction to our screens druckman
honestly outdid himself with this one
there's a brilliant sequence where Joel
desperately tries to reload in silence
to avoid detection while also dodging
glass shards on the ground these are all
mechanics from the game series and these
are far from all the callbacks Made In
This Very episode alone this is honestly
The Last of Us at the peak of its horror
for now and all I can do is just gush
the part where Joel and Ellie
desperately try to creep around the
display cabinet is so familiar from all
our playthroughs and not to mention the
clicker diving onto Joel is framed
identically to that found in the game
also and before I move on with so much
gameplay having been cut out and
mechanics like spores omitted entirely
Ellie getting bitten in this scene
suddenly became essential in the games
Joel is convinced of the legitimacy of
Ellie's immunity by her being able to
breathe in the spores without getting
infected and so naturally in the TV show
with her being bitten this acted as a
natural and easy way to remedy that
small hole that needed filling similarly
to the museum and all the levels that
changed prior the capital building
sequence is largely overhauled too while
the conversation that reveals Tess is
infected is largely similar the vibe is
quite different in in the Companion
podcast that was released alongside each
episode's airing Troy Baker noted that
he loved the little Flinch Pedro Pascal
did towards anatore as she stepped
towards him during that very reveal
further adding that he was annoyed he
didn't do it himself druckman and Mason
also go on to mention that these magical
moments are actually the reason why they
intend for their actors not to look at
the games prior to playing the
characters themselves as they don't want
them to Simply copy the original
performances but to instead make it
their own and while I do plan on talking
about her closer to the end of this
video I will say that Pedro Pascal's
Joel is noticeably different to the
game's version both in a good and
potentially bad way that I will be
touching on later in addition to those
minor changes there are other more
substantial ones to touch on fedra no
longer infiltrates the building to kill
Tess what makes the last of us a great
game is that each level in sequence is
designed with the gameplay in mind this
scene is no different with Tessa's
sacrifice transitioning smoothly into
the gameplay as Joel and Ellie need to
find their way out of fedger's control
area however the challenge presented to
this episode is that unlike the game
which could continue the narrative into
more gameplay this needs to be the final
scene to cap off the episode in a
satisfying fashion and naturally
significant changes were made like
nixing the federal Squad entirely in
favor of antagonizing the massive horde
we saw earlier to rush the capital
through those very root systems Mason
did also mention that he didn't believe
the original sequence made much sense
with Phedra he said why would they be so
far out of the qz I'm personally I don't
know if that's necessarily a fair
criticism given the implication in the
original was that fedra were actively
trying to take out the fireflies but I
do think this change works a lot better
for the conclusion of this episode and
when The Horde breaches the building
Tess freezes up and backs into a corner
most of them ignoring her implying that
she's already part of them to an extent
and I thought that was a beautiful touch
and man that kiss the kiss is horrifying
taking something so beautiful in a
normal situation and corrupting it by
placing it in a horrifying context is
honestly pretty genius druckman spoke
about this idea being that the fungus
just wants to spread and it's not always
violent though to me what makes this
scene so genius is that it is still
violent but in a very different way it's
horribly invasive and watching Tess
struggle to fight the corruption almost
giving up only to finally muster the
last strength to light the lighter it's
an incredible moment and once again in
the Companion podcast Mason mentions
that the idea behind this event with
respect to Joy and Ellie was that Joel
looks at Ellie now as the one at Falls
for what has just happened and has no
real interest in whether she comes along
at this point or not all the while as we
soon find out Ellie blames Joel also
I live in this world you live in a
psycho bunker where 911 was an inside
job and and the government are all Nazis
the government are all Nazis one aspect
afforded by The Last of Us transitioned
to TV is the ability to change
perspectives in the game you're always
seeing events from the perspective of a
player's character and that's largely in
service of the immersion factor of the
game it may not be your story but
there's a sense of at least wanting to
ground you within the character's
perspective while we've seen aspects of
diverging from this in the previous
episodes like Marlene's Firefly base or
test being interrogated by Robert this
marks the first complete shift of the
series it casts aside an entire section
of the game in favor of a unique story
and challenges fans in ways the prior
episodes did not and yet what's so
fascinating to me is that in spite of
that this episode is one of if not the
best written episodes of the entire
Series in spite of this being the most
pervasive opinion of the episode there
have been an unfortunate number of
people who didn't see it that way they
don't see the Thematic importance of the
episode as an analog of Ellie and Joel's
story one that informs actions going
forward and produces a fundamental
change in Joel's character and while
there are certainly many valid reasons
one might criticize the contents of this
episode 4 there is one angle that just
didn't sit right with me the entire
episode
has no zombies
no real threat
and it is about two gay dudes who meet
and have a relationship in which one
grows strawberries for the other and
then they die given the nature of my job
I don't get to say this all too often
but Ben's reading and criticism of the
episode here is objectively wrong and
I'm being incredibly charitable by
limiting my criticism of his analysis to
just that but look I'll address these
criticisms later this story isn't about
Ben and this story has so much more to
offer that for one reason or another has
flown under the radar for some folks and
so you may consider this section of the
video for those that did not enjoy this
episode maybe I can help change your
mind maybe I can't but either way I hope
you look at this with an open mind
contrary to what Ben has asserted this
episode isn't about quote two gay dudes
in fact while 45 minutes of the runtime
does contend with the lives of Bill and
Frank 30 minutes of the episode deals
specifically with Joel and Ellie and
while those scenes with Joel and Ellie
specifically lend necessary exposition
to the world and explore their
characters more it's what those 45
minutes with Bill and Frank offer to the
main NGO that elevates this episode from
just another flashback to one of the
most impressive episodes of the Season
some viewers might describe the last of
us as a story about people during the
apocalypse and while that's of course
not incorrect it goes a hell of a lot
deeper than that it's a story that
concerns itself with people struggling
to hold on to their Humanity in a world
that forces them to be inhumane and
additionally it's a story about choices
that's what the last of us is all about
and this episode is the perfect
distillation of that very message I
mentioned earlier in this video that The
Last of Us is my single favorite game of
all time I've played it to completion at
least 10 times over at this stage and to
be honest Bill's section with its more
high contrast visuals quirky traps and
terrifying enemy Revelations
consistently held the top spot as my
favorite section to play through and
that's the problem here it was my
favorite section to play through it is
wall-to-wall gameplay with short
expository sections and comedy leaning
cutscenes that for brief moments
revealed some tenderness and so going in
I knew that there would have to be
changes to make this work but I had
expected it to be a fairly conventional
episode with an action set piece at the
school and maybe some flashbacks here
and there to flesh out the relationship
Bill had with his partner Frank who's
really just a footnote in the game prior
to discovering his corpse and note
towards the end of that section and
really never in a million years did I
expect the show to have taken that
footnote of a plot Point flipped it on
its head and extrapolated it into an
episode that not only works in isolation
but manages to do more for Joel and
Ellie than the game did in this section
nobody made you go along with this plan
you needed a truck battery or whatever
and you made a choice
so don't blame me for something that
isn't my fault
scene after seeing this episode
continues to work in service of its main
Jewel and it is so wonderfully handled
towards the beginning of this episode
Ellie is the one who opens up and takes
the initiative to ease the tensions
between herself and Joel following the
Fallout of the prior episode the level
of maturity she demonstrates here is one
clearly forced from lived experience and
one that exposes the hulls in Joel's
facade here and despite begrudgingly
accepting these extensions to his quest
in delivering Ellie to Bill it's clear
from this point on he slowly starts to
share more of himself with her and in
addition to that fills her in on the
horrors outbreak they had on the small
towns in remote regions this naturally
transitions into the main meat of the
episode then that acts as a metaphor an
analog to the main story at hand one
that explains in Greater detail the sort
of person Joel has become while also
Illuminating that there's still hope for
him if the right person can come along
to reignite his will to live and not
simply just survive as soon as Bill pops
onto our screens we get to enjoy the
overtlyness and survival Madness he's
associated with in the games quite
quickly we see him setting the
foundations of what will eventually
become his insulated world of
self-sufficiency placed against
uncharacteristically upbeat rock music
this Montage does wonders for
characterizing Bill in an instant
thereby allowing the plot to search
forward into its introduction of the
episode's other key player Frank in the
game our sole encounter with Frank is
with his corpse sometime after he's
decided to end his own life he's a pair
of dangling legs and a suicide note that
reveals a deeply troubled relationship
with Bill to the point where he claimed
he never even liked him in the first
place it's an upsetting moment that
clearly has its own thematic through
line but it's very much an easily missed
background detail instead the show takes
this idea of a couple in an isolated
town in the apocalypse and reworks it
into a love story one that explores what
it means to give yourself over to
another person to listen to do things on
your own terms and in many ways to find
your true self emerge out of the ashes
of the Apocalypse bill is deeply
repressed and closed off and that's seen
visually in the way he conducts himself
whether it be his awkwardly hunched
posture or the way he can barely relax
or sit down smoothly thanks to the gun
holster to his thigh Frank stands in
complete opposition to that he's very
open and relaxed around Bill and seems
to truly understand him from the get-go
this is you
just from looking through the sheet
music on the piano Frank has a real
sense of who bill is and I just love
this slow Rising romantic tension
between the two as Bill's nature is
slowly pulled out of him by this
newfound stranger It ultimately Peaks
when Bill sits down at the piano and
that stiffness we've seen entirely
dissipates that tough rugged bordering
unmasculine parody of a man slips away
and instead what emerges is a man
singing his truth its delicate beautiful
and with all the Finesse in the world
you can almost feel the exhale of relief
in the silence as he finishes that song
and the reveal that Frank already sussed
out Bill's sexuality before they kissed
is just breathtakingly beautiful and
from that blossoming point the two
characters just fall in love Bill having
met the one person capable of breaking
through his mental barriers accepting
him and loving him for the person he is
but Bill is still bill at the end of the
day he's a Survivor a protector and now
he has someone he needs to fight for to
protect and he does exceptionally well
in in that role but as Frank points out
that isn't enough in this story Frank
represents life and Humanity providing
an answer to why we survive why we
continue to fight on in the face of
certain destruction and chaos and this
philosophy is seen not just in how he
acts as the perfect Catalyst for Bill to
open up to but also acts as the means
with which he meets Joel and Tess two
people who provide bill with what he
needs to continue to protect and survive
along with his partner Frank it's clear
that without people like Joel and Bill
in this world we have no chance of
survival but this scene also points out
that without those like Frank and Ellie
we lose our reason to keep fighting with
the most obvious instance of that coming
by way of Frank selling one of Bill's
guns to get a luxury item strawberry
seeds and following the shock of such a
frivolous trade Bill Giggles with joy
once he tries one of the berries once
again letting his tough guy guard down
frame moment to just enjoy life and
that's who Frank is he is life and as
soon as Frank starts to fade away
because Bill can now see the value in
this upkeep of the town he starts to
take over Frank's duties with their
final dinner acting as one of the many
moments where this very element of the
story is laid to bear I'm old
I'm satisfied
and you were my purpose
and fittingly this final dinner mirrors
their very first in many ways everything
from where Frank sits to how Bill serves
him his food down to the finest detail
but there are key differences this time
around there's no more guard up no more
sitting at opposite ends of the table no
more measured dialogue no gun strapped
to his thigh any longer Frank was his
purpose and now he has nothing left to
fight for nothing left to protect
nothing left to guard he makes the
choice to go out on his own terms
leaving behind what was a wonderful life
with his entire world Frank held close
in his arms it's a beautiful scene and
one that so powerfully Echoes the
tagline of the show when you're lost in
the darkness look for the light
Frank and Bill found the light in each
other and what a privilege it is to be
able to extinguish that on their own
terms in a world just so ready to tear
away that from them quote this isn't the
tragic suicide at the end of the play
it's so perfectly Bittersweet and has
rightfully become one of the most talked
about moments of the show but for me
it's what follows this phenomenal scene
that cut right down to my core
I'm guessing you found this Joel because
anyone else would have been electrocuted
or blown up by one of my traps
back in the present Joel is confronted
by the words of his late counterpart in
that letter and he's forced to contend
with his own personal failures his own
shortcomings and what he needs to do to
set things right it results in a
powerful moment of Silent Agony as Joel
steps outside to take in what he's just
hurt and for the first time in this
story without being forced to without
being asked to Joel volunteers to take
Ellie the next step of the way on his
own accord he will not fail again and
that is the single biggest piece of
character development he's seen since
the outbreak in episode one Ellie is
Joel's why and you found purpose she's
the reason he has to live now and soon
she will become a vehicle that will
deliver Joel his long-lost Humanity
Frank is Ellie in this story made clear
by the fact that she takes Frank's very
gun from the cabinet that he used to
protect bill when the Raiders attacked
his town it's this powerful parallel and
development on top of what already works
as an incredible Standalone story that
makes criticisms like Shapiro so mind
boggling and incorrect this isn't filler
you cannot take this out without losing
anything I cannot fathom walking away
from this episode with this impression
and to be blunt for those that do it
reeks of a severe lack of media literacy
this episode is pivotal and while I
adore the counterpart in the game from a
gameplay perspective what this episode
offers from a storytelling perspective
against its game counterpart is night
and day as scripts in this story go
there are few that stand up to the
Brilliance of this one it is so well
conceived so well thought out and so
stunningly acted by Bella Pedro Nick and
Murray this episode it not only gave us
a fantastic love story but offered us
our very own light to look for in the
Darkness
why are all these Pages stuck together
uh
I'm just [__] with you
pacing is an essential part of
Storytelling particularly long-form
storytelling like a TV show not just in
terms of keeping the plot moving for the
sake of your audience's entertainment
but also managing the tension levels of
the episode experience itself it's
important to be able to take a breath
and decompress or that constant level of
intensity starts to fatigue or at worst
becomes muted or boring that deep breath
of relief is precisely what this episode
functions as and it's an episode I had a
real change of heart about between my
weekly viewing and my binge viewing to
be clear I enjoyed this episode both
times around but when watching week to
week I did find it to be strangely
lacking in Impact compared to the prior
episodes and yet when watched back to
back with those prior episodes the fact
that it's a very low key and
character-driven piece is nothing but a
plus if not necessary those first three
episodes were exhausting Sarah's death
Tess's death and of course Bill and
Frank's emotional gut punch of a suicide
are tiring enough let alone when you
consider the sheer weight of the
outbreak the Clickers set piece and
Joel's reaction to Bill's letter in only
three episodes there's a real sense of
an exhausting Journey starting to form
and so to be able to just slightly
exhale and explore Joel and Ellie's
characters is great and I'm glad this
episode exists in the form that it does
there are a huge number of changes from
the corresponding section of the game
here and they begin right from the
get-go following the acquisition of the
truck in the game there's a very brief
conversation with Bill where he gives
you a gas life and shoe before the game
jumps you right into the cassette tape
moment and sticky Pages gag for a split
second of respite before speeding ahead
into the inner city section of action it
works given how Bill's Town plays out in
the game but given the TV show just
produced one of the most tragic moments
in all of Television additional
breathing room was 100 required to
smooth this transition over and as a
result this episode begins with Ellie
alone in a run-down bathroom examining
her newly acquired pistol with her
trademark curiosity pouring over the
weapon with somewhat discomforting
Intrigue in the same way she did with
the trapped infected in the previous
episode or the way she looked on at
Joel's violence in episode one it's
uncomfortable but it's not Sinister this
is a girl who wants to be a Survivor to
avoid repeating what she considered
mistakes in the past and to become an
asset to Joel in the present rather than
just cargo as he so called her earlier
it's this build up to Ellie's
self-sufficiency and Independence that
results in the winter section of the
story working so well and why her place
as the ultimate asset in the ending of
the story and a particular choice made
there is so divisive it's a small
addition but one that serves a multitude
of purposes when looked at in
conjunction with other small additions
and in the grand scheme of the story the
show then returns to Great faithful
Renditions of the game following this
with Joel siphoning gas from nearby cars
a fun nod to build his gift in the game
and of course Ellie pulls out her joke
book an aspect of the game that exists
exclusively through dialogue delivered
during gameplay as I mentioned earlier
to Simply Stitch cutscenes together
would remove so much of what makes the
last of us so special to me it's these
little moments that add a lot of not
only Ellie's characterization but also
her bond with Joel and why this
adaptation is utterly fantastic just
navigating through the world and
listening to Ellie and Joel interact
does so much of the heavy lifting and
it's clear that Mason and Rockman
understand this following the iconic
sticky Pages moment the show takes a
literal turn off road and invents a
sequence of the pair camping in the
woods it's a scene that entirely exists
to recreate those aforementioned
feelings captured through gameplay we
learn of Joel's love of coffee for
example something that likewise
exclusively existed through gameplay But
ultimately what this scene does here is
begin to break down the barriers between
Joe and Ellie it works on three levels
for Joel he's a teacher a father and a
guardian he explains the dangers of
lighting a fire as it would alert not
the infected but people in danger of
this world that Ellie had considered the
extent of and of course foreshadows the
subject matter of not just this episode
but the next he finishes her scarecrow
joke and finally cracks a smile the one
moment he finally lets his guard down
across these first few episodes but I
think the most critical scene here is
the guardian element Ellie shows her
first instance of legitimate
vulnerability a simple question about
whether anyone will find them in the
woods and while Joel pretends to be
asleep incapable at this point of truly
playing an uninhibited Father Figure he
stays up all night guarding her it's
such a simple addition that told us only
five minutes of screen time but it's so
vital in unpacking this complex
relationship that's beginning to form
here and as they jump back into the car
and head forwards the show Once Again
finds itself on the rails of
faithfulness to the game with a slight
twist while the game sees them heading
to Pittsburgh the show swaps this to
Kansas City for the sake of realism as
far as travel time and location goes but
also because they felt the shooting
location in Calgary looked absolutely
nothing like Pittsburgh and it's that
concern for realism that sees the famous
ambushine play out slightly differently
too while the game has them rammed by a
huge truck crashing spectacularly and
then single-handedly mowing down 10
enemies the show opts for tire spikes
and a brick dropped on a windshield with
the number of enemies reduced to just
three it's the first stage in a severe
overhaul to the game there's a huge
chunk of gameplay removed here with many
moments shifted around in Aid of pacing
thematic competence and suitability for
a TV series for pacing and TV series
suitability Joel and Ellie no longer
make their way through a large stretch
of the city evading Bandits becoming
separated and exploring the hotel the
latter having been moved to episode 2.
however it's the Thematic competence
that I find the most interesting here
Joel is caught by surprise in both the
game and TV show and Ellie saves him but
the way these scenes play out couldn't
be more different and not just because
of where they take place Ellie executes
the guy with a surprise gunshot to the
forehead in the game while the TV series
sees her slowly build to making the
decision to shoot the enemy and it's not
a kill that is such a fantastic change
that serves the story so well for a
number of reasons as I've mentioned
Basin has been very vocal about how
violence is perceived in live action
versus a game and I think that is
arguably the most true here a child
murdering a man is a major event no
matter what you're watching and yet the
game sees Ellie react like this I shut
the hell out of that guy huh that
doesn't exactly convey the type of
trauma one would experience for that to
actually happen and I would argue that
Ellie making the kill here in live
action would severely undermine the
impact of her first legitimate murder
found in the winter section of the show
instead we see hesitation horror and a
terrifying realization of the impact of
her violence as the shot only maims
rather than kills Bella Ramsay's
performance as Ellie listens to Joel
finishing the job is fantastic you can
see the trauma that's forming she's
hyperventilating there's a blank look in
her eyes it's all so masterfully done
and to me completely obliterates the
game's version of events here and it is
yet another terrific example of the
showrunner's Mantra of if we change
something it has to be better and man
this is certainly better
there
have I satisfied the necessary
conditions for you to talk for lack of a
better term one of the most gamey parts
of The Last of Us was its Pittsburgh
section the bandits who commandeer
Federal vehicles and weapons are a
faceless enemy and the armored truck
they have is merely a constant presence
designed to drive the player through to
the next story beat anything that
occurred in this city prior to the
pair's arrival is left in the background
and that just wasn't ever going to work
in a TV setting without feeling
undercooked and so instead the show
gives these Bandits an identity by
creating a brand new subplot led by an
original character by the name of
Kathleen she leaves these Bandits with
her second in command Perry Someone fans
from the games might recognize as
Tommy's voice actor Kathy's brother was
murdered by Federer which led to the
Insurrection that took place and she's
after Henry and Sam for giving him up
two very important characters for the
next episode it's a very simple addition
to the story and one that I think is far
better explored in episode 5. but I
appreciate the way it weaves connective
tissue between these three parties
involved here despite only having around
seven minutes of screen screen time in
the 45 minute episode it results in
everyone having a clear motivation and
so the pieces now move into place in a
way that feels much more organic than
its video game counterpart would have
and while I'm not sure it's quite so
easy to understand how Kathleen ended up
in this position without the context
provided in episode 5. ultimately the
episode is very much about Joel and
Ellie it's a character piece more than
anything and far more important than I
first gave it credit for and I'm not
sure spending extra time on Kathleen in
this episode would have best served its
intentions oh wow yeah following Ellie's
saving Joel there's a wonderful scene
that shows Joel incapable of knowing how
to comfort Ellie properly something I
think contrasts very well against the
aftermath of the David episode it shows
him finally giving her some
responsibility with a weapon and taking
on the teacher role once again and of
course the episode ends with Joel
finally letting his guard down and
laughing at her jokes but not before
ensuring the room is safe teacher father
Guardian this episode is the turning
point for the pair and the perfect
breather and relief from the sheer
emotional gut punches that preceded it
but it is not without its own shocking
moment as the painted face of a young
boy stares down with his gun pointed
right at Joel
thank you
the title of each episode holds
significance within each story that
speaks not only to something specific in
the world of the last of us but
additionally tells us something about
the emotional or thematic significance
each episode serves to satisfy episode
ones when you're lost in the darkness
points quite obviously to the first half
of the famous fireflies quote literally
everywhere all over that episode but and
more importantly illuminates for us the
darkness Joel currently has lost himself
within having lost his daughter that
episode also episode 2's infected
naturally speaks to the event where in
test dies but additionally works as a
metaphor for Hope Joel and Tess have
spent years perhaps decades without hope
and that's how they've survived but now
Ellie has stumbled into their lives and
infected it with hope and finally
episode 3's long long time title points
again quite obviously towards the Linda
Ronstadt track but also thanks to the
storytelling within the episode acts as
The Motif for the bond between both Joel
and Ellie and not just bill and Frank
it's the theme of unity in that episode
and so keeping that in mind mind I'd
like to look at this episode at least
partially through the lens of its title
endure and survive and the Canon event
or quote this endure and survive title
stems from is a phrase from a comic book
enjoyed by both Ellie and Sam once the
two groups eventually converge speaking
of which within this episode we follow
three separate groups of Interest Joel
and Ellie Henry and Sam and finally a
new original character in Kathleen
alongside her forces when we first beat
Henry and Sam they're hiding like rats
in this dreary attic stabbing themselves
in an attempt to get away from the
vengeful Kathleen who unbeknownst to
them will soon be hunting Joel and Ellie
following their abrupt and impactful
arrival this I thought was an effective
way of bonding us to Henry and Sam from
the outset aligning them with Joel and
Ellie the main characters against a
common evil in Kathleen all the while we
get to relive some of the key moments
from their arrival in Kansas City
Through The Eyes of Henry himself Henry
and his younger brother Sam were two of
my favorite supporting characters Joel
and Ellie met along their way to Seattle
in the first game and truth be told I
prefer this iteration of them in live
action and that is something I never
anticipated to say however I think it is
thanks partially to some key changes
that the scriptwriters have made to them
with the largest of those changes coming
by way of Sam's New Age what was once a
13 year old boy in the games has now
been aged down to an eight-year-old boy
with one additional added complication
Sam is now deaf and as a result these
changes completely alter the dynamic
between his brother every other
character he engages with and even the
environment itself that he has to try
and navigate there are sequences where
Henry reacts to a noise only for Sam to
react to Henry's reaction whether that
be the crash outside or glass he steps
on and with monsters that rely on sound
to see in this world Sam is entirely
reliant on his loving older brother
which means to Sam Henry is his entire
world and their Dynamic reflects that
not just in the lengths Henry will go to
to protect and provide for his younger
brother but additionally in how Sam
views his older brother as mentioned
earlier endure and survive is a phrase
uttered in salmonelli's favorite comic
book much like in the very comic book
referenced Heroes both real and
imaginary serve a prominent role in this
episode
the most obvious reference to this is
seen early on when Henry paints a red
mask on his younger brother's face to
help him find the courage to come out of
hiding but more easily missed are some
creative camera tricks to give Henry
that same effect like I said Henry is
Sam's hero and the director wants us to
not only feel and understand that from a
script writing perspective but also from
a visual perspective and with shots like
this where a storefront's reflection
creates for Henry his very own mask I
don't know what more you could ask for
in terms of visual storytelling here
we don't want to hurt you
we want to help you
okay
the greater episode itself is a real
love letter to the game and I'm actually
really surprised this section was kept
largely the same albeit with locations
shifted around one difference I didn't
take much notice of until I began my
analysis was that of Joel and Henry's
coming together in the games Henry
blindsides you as you're climbing in
through a window fleeing from a faceless
fedra and largely the result the
live-action version comes to is the same
or so I thought Henry and Sam do get the
jump on Joe and Ellie and quickly see
them as allies that they can work with
to get out of the city but the way with
which they are jumped has a very
different source and power Dynamic at
play one that speaks the fear and
motivation of Joel later on in the story
unlike the game Joel isn't fleeing from
anything he's not in some room he hasn't
inspected and unlike the game this
Advantage Henry and Sam were able to get
on Joel wasn't a blind side it instead
came about because of Joel's own
personal shortcomings he's deaf in one
ear and unlike Sam he has no one he can
rely on this isn't drawn attention to in
the episode but it's specifically speaks
to a certain scene in the next and it's
one that directly ties to the hero motif
of this episode too in this instance
Joel has failed Ellie this surprise
attack could have resulted in his or her
own death had it been literally anyone
else in the city looking for them and
this isn't the only instance Joel feels
less than in this episode either Joel
didn't have a plan to get out of the
city and once he starts following
Henry's plan running into a building
he's visibly exhausted feeling his age
and as they get down to the maintenance
tunnels he fails to see the utility in
allowing Sam and Ellie the time they
need to unwind and gather themselves
suddenly the father teacher Guardian
standard he wants to uphold starts to
feel like a hopeful delusion however
with those changes to Joel's Outlook in
this section the scenery is kept
remarkably faithful to the original game
albeit with locations like I mentioned
shifted around seeing druckman and Mason
actually maintaining the story of ish
and keeping the kids portraits off him
on the wall was a wonderful touch it's
such an easily missed part of the game
if you were to ignore those notes and
I'm so glad that they were in included
however it's the change in dialogue
during this sequence that really made me
fall in love with this version of Henry
over that which I'm used to in the game
while he's still trying to do everything
for his brother there's an element to
him that's far more complicated being
Sam's only remaining Guardian he reveals
that in an effort to save his life he
handed over the leader of the resistance
and Kathleen's brother leading to the
man's death this reveal naturally grants
Kathleen a much more humanized presence
in the story however it's how Henry
Sam's hero described himself during this
conversation with Joel that I really
took note of yeah so still think they
should take it easy on me
am I the bad guy this reveal naturally
grants Kathleen a much more humanized
presence in the story however it's how
Henry Sam's hero describes himself
during this conversation that I thought
was quite telling Henry is torn apart by
what he's done and sees himself Unworthy
of pity and moral consideration from
Joel he doesn't see himself as a hero
but a quote bad guy and if I don't say
it now Lamar Johnson as Henry steals
this episode hand over fist this
performance is breathtakingly sincere
and subtle and I'd love to see this man
in more shows and films but back on
topic this feeling of not being worthy
being less than that both Joel and Henry
are feeling at this moment once again
speaks to the philosophy of both the
comic and this episode's namesake endure
and survive that's all they can do
welcome where they are we're almost
there [__] Kathleen is an interesting
character in these episodes her presence
has some great qualities for certain
unfortunately those qualities don't have
anything to do with her character
writing with that said she did offer a
lot in the way of thematic and
structural significance to the story at
hand to at least justify her existence
unlike the other two groups in this
episode each has at least one hero to
follow Kathleen has lost her older
brother the leader of the resistance and
her hero and while she is now the leader
of the resistance it's her irresponsible
actions which leads to their ultimate
downfall this is emphasized further with
Kathleen's fate had she simply endured
and survived or Familia loss she would
have never doomed her City every poor
decision she makes is driven by an
unwavering Lust For Revenge ignoring the
basement mindlessly hunting Henry and
with all that we know that lies on the
horizon for this very story it's
impossible not to see the groundwork
being laid here for future episodes and
Seasons quote is the world worth one kid
as a small footnote out I will say that
I thought Kathleen's character was
portrayed much better in this episode
than the last I don't think she was
necessarily an issue in the last episode
but I think she was perhaps better
directed in giving a performance that
really sold the whole cam but ruthless
Vibe here in this one but on the whole
though I don't think her subplot was all
that well executed it does serve the
plot well and that it unifies the
characters against a singular threat but
it's not all that compelling on its own
and while not receiving much in the way
of screen time in the last episode this
one remedies that right away however
outside of that I can say I enjoyed how
Kathleen was characterized nor how
inconsequential she ultimately felt
thankfully she wasn't replacing anything
meaningful in terms of story so there's
nothing from the original that's ruined
here so to speak it's just not elevated
in the same level that drachmann and
Mason have managed to do in other areas
with their fresh material and that's all
to say that taking a dense section of
gameplay where the only antagonistic
force is a truck and turning it into a
character with a core motivation is
still a net positive but it's a very
loose motivation and ultimately I think
that character still ends up feeling
like an armored truck a plot device to
unite characters and move them from one
place to the next
I got a gush for a second but the sniper
sequence being kept almost one to one
genuinely made me leap out of my chair
in excitement it's one thing keeping the
tunnel settlement the same but I
couldn't believe they kept the sniper
section and played it almost identically
through I mean this thing is one of the
most gamey segments of the last of us
and here it is almost untouched the
layout of the area the way the events
play out it's all authentic naturally
the show does take some creative
Liberties here and there by dining it up
to 11 and presenting us with the largest
threat of infected since episode two I
mean that thing is like something
straight out of World War Z and
combining it with this resistance
confrontation only enhances the action
climax for me
oh
introducing the bloater to the series
here is new as it was first introduced
in the game long ago during the build
section towards its latter stages its
rendition is super faithful albeit
missing the Spore element for reasons
we've already discussed the hybrid of
CGI and practical effects used to bring
this scene to life from the costumes to
the extras to the sets themselves it's
all just so perfectly done despite not
being from the game itself this Rush of
infected coupled with the strong
presence of the bloater here really
stand out to me as the defining action
set piece of the season with regards to
the infected at the very least it's just
so much fun with one of the coolest
details I noticed being Perry's death
looking awfully familiar now why is that
well maybe it's because it's straight
out of the game apparently Mason and
druckman owned an odd about including
the bloater here at all which is
interesting to me but did eventually
decide to include it and portray it as
this unkillable Beast to contrast it
against the video game Boss Vibes it
gave off in the first game in addition
to that on the design front the child
clicker was designed by one of the the
original games clicker designers which
has nothing to do with the story but was
a neat detail I thought might be
interesting to share with all of that
praise aside however I do have a few
criticisms I'd like to give voice to The
Surge of swarming infected is one of the
most exciting and cinematic scenes in
this series and I have a couple of
issues with it the scene where the truck
drives through the building and sinks
into the ground thus releasing the horde
of clickers Runners stalkers and one big
fat bloater while awesome feels
incredibly convenient to me and it
didn't need to be that the odds of there
being a weak point right beneath that
building that they happen to crash into
that wasn't alluded to before just rubs
me the wrong way simply because the
video game did it better and the TV show
had already laid the groundwork
necessary to recreate it even better
than the game did in the game you in
control of Joel need to cover Ellie
salmon Henry as they avoid fedra and
eventually because of the noise caused
by Federer and you with the sniper the
swarm of infected that rushed the scene
naturally as I pointed out prior I'm not
against TV shows changing things
sometimes they're necessary and thus far
more often than not they add a ton to
the story being told but I don't think
they needed to change as much as they
ultimately did here in this episode with
episode 2 having established the fungal
root systems this would have literally
been the perfect time to use that
mechanic again we've seen the sinkhole
in the city from the episode prior and
we've got an irresponsible leader
willing to tear down anything in our way
to get what she wants why not have her
carelessly rip through tendrils thus
alerting the sinkhole full of infected
to Surge more causing it to erupt that's
just one way to use it and perhaps there
are infinitely better ways but my point
is that outside of just episode 2 this
fascinating new mechanic isn't used once
and that's such a wasted opportunity to
me particularly when this felt a little
contrived in spite of the underground
infected being set up previously
unfortunately this serves as the last
major infected set piece of the season
for me the last of us has three pillars
Joel Ellie and The Infected they're one
of the most iconic parts of the game
when you think of The Last of Us you
think of the bond between jolly and you
think of the horrors of the infected and
while I don't think this threat needs to
be in every episode as the last thing
you want is to reduce their impact I do
think their presence falling into the
background at this Midway Point hurts
one key pillar of this series and more
critically subdues the importance of
Ellie's existence though I'll touch on
this a little more later in episode 8
analysis
oh
in the game salmonella's relationship is
friendly and almost flirtatious with how
Sam tries to play a cool around her and
even pretends to be the same age as
Ellie in the show however their bond is
akin to something siblings would have
it's all based on a sense of joy and
camaraderie and Ellie feels a real
desire to protect him this all comes to
a head when Sam confides in La that he's
bit and she desperately and perhaps
naively tries to use her blood to save
him that right there is one of the most
meaningful changes the show has made yet
and there's no way that isn't a pivotal
point in season 2 when Ellie confronts
Joel about the choice he took from her
it's another terrific creative change
and while the game's version is still
effective the whole I'm bitten but I'm
gonna hide it until it's too late Trope
is very played out in this genre and I
think that would have been felt far more
strongly in live action now that we're
over 10 years removed from the original
story's release and so instead of that
Trope the show offers us a tender
emotional moment and lets the audience
wallow in the futility of Ellie's
efforts to save him Ellie reinforce the
fact that she is the symbol of Hope and
Humanity in this cruel and inhumane
World refusing to sit back and just let
this happen doing everything in her
innocent power to help in whatever
little way she can but it's not enough
she failed to stay up with him like he
asked and she failed to save him with
her blood and to add insult to injury
the way this scene plays out sadly hints
at Sam's question from the night before
are people still in there Sam didn't
attack Ellie during the night because he
simply didn't hear her it's only when
she touches him that he pounces we know
from episode 1 on the catatonic old lady
that the infected can heal but it takes
time before it fully takes over and so
the implication here is that Sam's not
quite fully gone speaking on the topic
Craig Mason said that those early stages
are like being on a hallucinogenic trip
where you can't control yourself and
with that in mind it really helps to add
a new layer of utter horror to this
scene expanding on the topic further Sam
was made deaf as Mason wanted to make
Henry and Sam feel distinct to that of
Joel andelli in the game you never
really see them alone and so the
interactions with Henry and Sam all felt
quite distinct to those you enjoy with
Joel and Ellie on TV however we get to
see their perspective before they meet
up with our main Duo this was a a
potential problem where just like the
video game and another father-like
figure and curious child it would have
felt like an exhausting retread of what
we've already seen in Joel and Ellie and
so I'm really glad that they changed
that the murder suicide in the scene
hurts so much more here too in the game
Henry reactively starts to blame Joel
before turning the gun on himself here
his line is changed to what did I do and
you just see that panic and realization
set in before he realizes that he has
nothing left he's lost his why his
reason to be alive his only family and
man this performance is again next level
by Lamar overall and thus far I've
really liked how this series is
structured such that every significant
encounter or plot Beat Speaks to that
part of Joel and Ellie's budding
relationship Test shows Joel how to
accept his responsibility Bill shows him
how to open up to new possibilities and
Henry and Sam now represent a further
development on that idea once again it's
definitely clear this is being written
with careful consideration of how the
story will eventually play out with each
traumatic event like this we're seeing
Ellie toughen up and in turn we see as
his desire to play guardian over her
gross it's such a perfect build up to
the alien Joel we'll see in the future
however I will say that in service of
those subsequent Seasons coming in the
future I fear that along the way we will
lose something that made that game's
experience as captivating as it was and
I plan on talking about this in Greater
detail towards the end of this video
once again and so for now let's call
this another great episode and move on
to
episode six kid
while a great deal of time has passed
throughout the previous episodes this
marks the first episode set in the
present with a lower third time skip
three months later the deaths of Sam and
Henry are a harrowing moment in both
mediums with the game opting for a hard
cut to Black following the suicide
leading into the fall section of the
game while the show lingers and
marinates in the tragedy for a little
longer and so this time Skip and season
change serves that same purpose it
demonstrates a dramatic shift and in
this case it's a shift in the
relationship between Joel and Ellie in
many ways this episode Works in direct
contrast to episode 4. it's a moment to
reset and marinate in the changes and
the tragedy but with the roles reversed
here following a humorous opening scene
with a familiar interrogation method
Joel experiences the first anxiety
attack of the episode over a fear that
this brother of his May well be gone
it's a moment of vulnerability like the
one Ellie showed while camping in
episode 4 a fear of the unknown ahead of
them these parallels further extend into
the camping scene of this episode that
follows where the same same teacher
father Guardian theme rears its head
once again and were privy to just how
much has changed over those months Joel
now outwardly cares he tells Ellie to
get down off a rock for fear of breaking
her neck he gives her a quick taste of
alcohol in a way I'm sure many of us can
relate to and in what is perhaps the
most powerful demonstration of this
change he recounts her favorite
astronauts so beautifully demonstrating
how much he's paid attention to her over
these months that they've shared as the
conversation continues Eddie reveals to
Joel that she's tried to save Sam with
her own blood and expresses sincere fear
and doubt over whether the fireflies can
really produce a vaccine from her blood
it's the same level of vulnerability
from episode 4 she's looking for
reassurance and now unlike that episode
where Joel was incapable of playing the
fatherly role he does so with confidence
here and while it was Joel who stayed up
to play Guardian to Ellie in that
episode here it's Ellie who steps into
that role it's not only a fun reversal
but it exists to demonstrate just how
much Joel has taught daughter she
recounts what to do perfectly and
although Joel is embarrassed for having
fallen asleep there's still that twinkle
of fatherly Pride seeing how capable she
is following his very teachings I really
do love just how closely those scenes
are mirrored by the way and to me I
think it demonstrates the real quality
of Craig Mason's writing and
understanding of this very material
these are some of my favorite unique
moments in the series and they're
exclusively there to fill in the
development found through conversations
had only in gameplay prior and I think
that could have run the risk of feeling
like awkward stitching between game
moments but they're woven in so
naturally and have clearly been given a
great deal of care and thought that they
work so well on this level
we're looking for any trouble we're just
passing through
as the duo are ambushed by Jackson's
inhabitants the first two very powerful
moments of unspoken character work are
present here throughout the series
Joel's had moments of PTSD seep in
almost exclusively linked to his trauma
with Sarah the first being in episode 1
where the guard holds up him Tess and
Ellie and now again as the fear that
Ellie would be detected as infected and
killed I love the way that this scene's
directed and you can really feel Joel
begin to disassociate as the piercing
ring plays out and almost all diegetic
sound Fades away these unspoken moments
of trauma are a common theme in this
episode and I think my favorite example
of it is found shortly after as they
make their way into the Jackson commune
and Joel reunites with Tommy while the
scene itself should be one of exclusive
positivity two brothers embracing after
a long time apart steeped in the unknown
of each other's well-being there's a
quiet sadness to it Elise framed as a
background element looking on with an
expression that just says so much one
that expresses a realization that she's
never experienced a familial Bond like
this and another that suggests a feeling
of insecurity and a fear of being
forgotten it's the first pin in an
important through line that sets up a
major emotional set piece later in this
episode and I was so happy to see it
handled so elegantly here
how about a tour
one of the many opportunities afforded
when adapting an existing property is
the power of hindsight while The Last of
Us Part one's game had a great deal of
money and Manpower behind it things like
time and technological limitations are
hard to avoid and with a sequel barely a
thought in druckman's mind at the time
there's only so much direct setup to be
found there and thus this part of the
series features a major overhaul in its
location and structure despite the key
events featured remaining the same what
originally took place at a dam in an
isolated Farmhouse is now relocated
directly within the Jackson commune
itself what's interesting about this
change is that this is actually
restoring Neil druckman's original
vision for this portion of the story
before settling for the damn sequence
the team at noidog were looking to build
Jackson for the introduction to Tommy
and Maria but due to the time and
processing power it would have taken to
build that on the PlayStation 3 Hardware
they were forced to scale back the idea
now however with near endless
possibilities and the power of foresight
of course this version of events not
only restores the original intent but
takes the opportunity to introduce the
many key elements of Jackson that will
soon become a a fundamental part of the
series moving forward following the
touching reunion with Tommy the pair
find themselves in a very familiar
setting to those who have played The
Last of Us Part 2. and with a surprise
onlooker watching Ellie eat while their
identity isn't revealed in the show
major fans may remember Dina recanting
this exact scenario in the game I did I
remember thinking who is this string
bean girl stealing all the jerky of
course the setup and references don't
end there were introduced to a young
Shimmer Ellie's horse in the game and
the movie night we see in this episode
is an aspect advertising posters in the
second game they're all wonderful little
Easter eggs for longtime fans but at the
same time they really do demonstrate the
team's commitment to the source material
and a forward-thinking attitude to the
grand scheme of the series as a whole
and what I really enjoy about this
understanding of the source material is
that it allows departures and reworkings
of sections to feel organic and lead
into upcoming scenes smoothly Maria's
distrust of Joel is brought to the
Forefront very quickly and Tommy
announcing his Emery relationship is
altered in a way that sees Joel's
reaction turn into one of surprisent
hurts begrudgingly congratulating them
when prompted by Ellie only it's an
important change as one of the major
overhauls of the episode comes in the
form of how Ellie learns of Sarah and
how Joel asks Tommy to take Ellie in the
former's case after being handed off yet
again by Joel Ellie finds himself alone
with Maria and this newfound perspective
allows the latter to receive a great
deal more character development than she
ever had in the game while we learned
that she was an attorney prior to the
outbreak it's the insight into her own
child's death that reveals a great deal
about how this shared trauma may be how
her and Tommy ended up together but I
think what's Most Fascinating is the
outcome of Maria revealing that Joel
once had a daughter who died Bella
Ramsay is so good that you can just see
the split-second feeling of betrayal of
having not been told this and this is so
important as it's ultimately yet another
strike in her feeling so completely cut
off from Joel at this point in this
story on the other side of things Jill
and Tommy find themselves alone catching
up in this town's bar and this is the
first of two scenes that were singular
in the game a discussion about their
violent-filled past and Joel's request
for Tommy to take Ellie off his hands is
One Singular very aggressive scene in
the game while here that request is
shifted to much later this newly
extended discussion is extremely
impressive at first Joel keeps his
trademark stiff upper lip and lies to
Tommy he says Tess is fine and that he
has decided to Simply pop in to see
Tommy on a profit-driven trip to deliver
a big wig's daughter I just love that
little bit of Deceit so much it really
sells Joel's humiliation of having
worried for nothing only to turn up and
see his brother living a near idealistic
lifestyle he asks for Tommy's help on
making it over the finish line of this
journey and it's here that aggression
from the game manifests when he refuses
but it's shifted it's Joel's insecurity
that brings up the murderous past and
it's Tommy who says there's no judgment
for it but when Tommy explains that
Maria's preg and Joel reacts Baddie to
it that aggression flips again
just because life stopped for you
doesn't mean it has to stop for me
what a powerful statement it's a
terrible thing to say to your brother
given he lost his child and it's clear
on Tommy's face he realizes that
immediately but what this does
thematically is just unbelievably
sophisticated and good it forces Joel to
recognize and confront his trauma and
how it's actively having an effect on
his ability to deliver and it leads to
the second panic attack the moment he
steps outside but he just cannot forgive
himself for this perceived failure to
protect Sarah and is just killing him
inside even the sight of a girl
resembling Sarah reminds him of what
could have been had he protected her had
he succeeded had he not failed it's such
a brilliant piece of acting and so well
directed and what this means however is
that the request for Tommy to take Ellie
by himself rather than with Joel is
shifted to a later part of the episode
in the game Joel asks Tommy and his men
to finish the job and when Tommy asks
what makes you think I'd do this for you
Joel snaps back saying that it's not for
him it's for the fireflies cause the
very people Tommy had joined prior to
settling down with Maria he so
aggressively asks for any kind of
solution to get Ellie off of his hands
and it almost seems out of character for
him at this point in the story it's as
though he doesn't care or sees her as a
burden but it becomes abundantly clear
as soon as he drops a line I need this
that it's a facade and that he is scared
terrified of failure and this is further
underpinned by his big emotional
reaction following the fight at the dam
where he frantically checks to see if
Ellie is okay the TV show however
presents this completely differently in
a way that ties itself into the trauma
that sits right at the Forefront of
Joe's character in this show it doesn't
bubble beneath the surface Mast by anger
it spills out here in one of the most
emotional scenes of the series Tommy
comes to apologize to Joel and it's here
Joel reveals Ellie's immunity and
Tessa's death the facade comes crashing
down and the truth comes spilling out a
brother pouring his soul out to his only
remaining kin after months of repressed
trauma and no Outlet you want me to take
her I'm just gonna get her killed I know
don't know it
and I have to leave her
this scene hurts it's a glimpse into a
tortured Soul one reflecting on every
bit of horror he's seen on this
harrowing journey and how he places all
the blame now on himself squarely it
affects every aspect of his being from
his sleep to his mental stability this
is a man broken by a broken World
terrified of failing once again quote I
was never afraid before you showed up as
Bill put it to Frank Joel is now so
keenly aware of his feelings for Ellie
at this point that it terrifies him his
natural reaction is to just push her
away and I can tell you as someone who
has pushed away many wonderful things in
life through anxiety or fear or failure
that is a powerful and deeply relatable
emotion and Pedro Pascal's performance
conveys that to utter Perfection and
while this show removes a section of
Ellie running off the results are
largely the same Ellie overheard the
conversation and thus a confrontation
must happen I'm not entirely convinced
this tracks quite as smoothly as the
game however since I think Joel's
aggressively trying to get rid of her
makes more sense to upset Ellie then her
overhearing and emotional Outburst of
the same request but at the same time I
think the show just about gets away with
it as this is the fourth notch in
Ellie's feeling of Abandonment within
this episode alone and I don't think a
rational response from someone of her
age after already feeling hurt is likely
or reasonable to expect ultimately it
doesn't particularly matter because what
follows is Sublime
everybody I have cared for
has either died or left me
everybody [__]
up for you
so don't tell me tell me save from
somebody else be
I would just be more scared this is my
favorite scene in the game and to see it
brought to life almost verbatim moved me
to tears and brilliantly it now works on
a different level it's a mirror of
Joel's scene this is Ellie's outpouring
of trauma to her only family she has
been through so much she is terrified of
being alone again and the thought that
this person in her life who she's come
to see like a father wants to leave her
it's too much what I find so fascinating
is that side by side with the game there
is a marked difference in the direction
of the scene Craig Mason mentioned they
changed the iconic quote you are
treading on some mighty thin ice line
because they felt it didn't fit with
their version of Joel and while I agree
I think it's arguably more to do with
how he is exclusively within this scene
in the game he is just boiling with rage
exhausted from tracking down Ellie and
taking on Bandits here there's a calmer
and quieter rage still emotionally
exhausted from his conversation with
Tommy and I think the choice to go with
a cold and whispery no
don't say another word
fits really well here and I don't find
myself missing the original game light
as much when I think about it that way
and as Joel walks away from the argument
having ruthlessly cast Ellie out he sits
and reflects on Sarah and I really like
that as an addition it lets the audience
marinate in the moment for much longer
compared to the game that launches into
an action set piece even the next scene
sees Ellie sitting by the window waiting
for someone to come and get her and I
love that fleeting look of
disappointment Bella gives as Tommy
enters the room you can just see for a
second that she was hopeful it would be
Joel it's a really nice extension of
uncertainty about the upcoming events
for new viewers and works quite well I
think for old fans too furthermore I
really like the change from Joel making
the decision for Ellie to come with him
again to him awkwardly giving her the
choice ashamed of his words from the
night before I think it not only makes
for a sweet and amusing moment given her
reaction but also creates an interesting
contrast to the end of the game that is
of course all about the removal of
choice I very much love the decision to
move Joel teaching Ellie how to use a
rifle to after after all of these
emotional scenes too the game had the
sequence immediately after Ellie saved
his life which would have had this
moment placed in the middle of episode 4
had the series done the same and I think
by moving it to here it allows the show
to convey how dumping all of that trauma
out in the table and being honest with
one another actually leads to a stronger
bond in the end and what better way to
demonstrate that than with a classic
parent-child teaching moment one of the
interesting tidbits about this episode
is its director yasmila uzbanich who was
originally asked to direct the previous
two episodes as she is Bosnian and had
not only lived through a terrifying
Siege of her City but made an
award-winning film about similar subject
matter at the time Mason felt that lived
experience would be perfect for
Kathleen's Siege of Kansas City however
yasmila was more passionate about using
her experience with survival through
solidarity to reflect the community of
Jackson and I think that came across
remarkably well she carefully studied
the game on YouTube and I think that's
so fundamentally clear to see in these
wonderful sections of Joel and Ellie
traveling across the country the use of
silhouette against the Setting Sun is
identical to shots found in this section
of the game and it sure does look
absolutely beautiful and on that topic
this episode has some of the best
visuals of the series likely due to her
using her longtime cinematographer
collaborator and I think that really
comes across here too but moving on as
Joel and Ellie arrive at the University
I think near every fan screamed in Joy
seeing so much of it Faithfully
recreated the monkeys the conversation
where Joel talks about wanting to be a
singer and okay committing to that
monkey jump scare Faker was honestly
brilliant they even threw in some
perfect setup for The Last of Us Part 2
and season 2 of this show by showcasing
a path from Seattle to Salt Lake City
unfortunately I think this is where this
phenomenal episode slightly stumbles
when held up in comparison to the game's
version of events this is a sequence
that naturally had to be changed for the
TV series it would have been ludicrous
for Ellie to fight off dozens of enemies
with a barely conscious jaw by her side
so it's not the scale or scope of the
encounter that I think is lacking but
rather the presentation of the aftermath
after Joel is impaled by rebar in the
game the intensity of the sequence
Rockets upwards and there's this
horrifying impending sense of Doom felt
as you fight your way to safety and when
safety comes the reality of Joel's wound
seeps in and it's the final nail in the
coffin as Joel Falls from his horse and
when compared to that I think the show
moves Just a Touch Too Fast here to
recreate that Rising tension after it
occurs I think perhaps some sort of
small set piece to show Ellie struggle
to escape would have gone a long way so
the audience could marinate a little
more in Joel's wound like the game
counterpart offered thankfully however I
do think the final moment of this
episode works as a great closer and
while I certainly don't feel as much
impact as I did from The Game's
counterpart it's been quite evident from
Reading newcomers reactions to this
moment that it certainly works here on
its own even if it might not quite
capture the full extent of what it's
adapting overall this is probably the
most emotionally rich and complex
episode of the series and if its only
fault is some slightly muted tension
it's final moments I think it's safe to
say that this is a real Contender for
one of the best episodes of the series
as a massive fan of this series when the
titles for each episode were released I
was very much interested specifically in
this episode's title Left Behind simply
because I knew what I was adapting and
despite having only played that once I
have exceptionally found memories of
that experience in spite of being
detached from the mainline game itself
this beloved DLC offers valuable insight
into Ellie's early years what her
upbringing was like how her sexuality
blossomed and what ultimately led to a
pivotal loss in her life that has
informed her desire to ensure nothing
like this happens to anyone ever again
the TV version of events is almost a
one-to-one recreation of this very story
with impressive editions pulling from a
tie-in comic book set in the same era it
honestly sounds like a perfect episode
right well
it kind of is in isolation unfortunately
it has a major issue that is impossible
to ignore at least for me it's one that
has nothing to do with its quality but
instead is all to do with its structure
and placing within the series as many
fans of the mainline game might remember
the Last of Us was released on the 14th
of June 2013 and within the game
comprises every episode of the series
bar one this one it is of course the DLC
that shares the same name as this
episode and was released eight months
later on Valentine's Day 2014. similarly
the comic book that also plays a small
part of the story was conceived of after
the mainline story was written according
to Neil drockman several months before
rapping the production of The Last of Us
Darkhorse Comics approached him to
produce a tie-in comic book series for
the game initially he was wary of the
idea but eventually agreed when he
realized they didn't want to do
something tangential and instead could
focus on expanding their characters and
universe beyond find what was seen in
the game itself this became the comic
book entitled The Last of Us American
Dream released between the 3rd of April
and the 31st of July 2013 alongside the
first game's release I mentioned these
dates because ultimately it shows that
left behind was very much something that
came after the main last of a story was
considered complete rather than an
unfinished part of its narrative that
was gutted and released later and so
much in the same way the Remake doesn't
insert it following Joel's impalement
and of course nobody would stop you to
play at Mid game for your first time
through I would say the same for the way
the TV series is structured you can
simply split a specific story in a
crucial moment that adds something to it
that wasn't there before without
creating some significant issues and so
before I dive into my analysis of this
episode proper and the game itself I'd
like to shine a light on how significant
Neil druckman himself viewed this part
of the story with the last of us we got
to see the events that led to who Joel
is during the game but we never get to
see that with Ellie with Ellie we're
picking her up at the outset of the
journey you see the events that are
shaping her and changing her and how she
loses the one person in this world that
she cares for then you understand why
she's willing to fight tooth and nail
not to lose Joel this is a story that
means the world to Neil druckman and
that's reflected in the script of this
very episode not only does everything
feel incredibly faithful from the
dialogue to the characters to the new
set pieces and scenes but this is the
only episode in the first season written
exclusively by Neil druckman himself
it's a story he believes in and loves
and from top to bottom this episode
tells its own compelling and
self-contained story while in similar
fashion to the games complementing its
more harrowing flashbacks with similar
struggles in present day with Joel Neil
has always said that he hated referring
to this post-game material as DLC
because he sees it as a valuable and
integral chapter to the story being told
in the whiter game and honestly I agree
with that notion Left Behind certain
really isn't your run-of-the-mill low
effort DLC this is a fully realized
backstory written by the main writer
himself of the series for a key
character that very much informed the
choices she makes and the action she
takes within the journey she and Joel go
on together and beyond that it's
exceptionally well written and the
design philosophy behind the game itself
from a mechanical perspective is very
sophisticated considering it is at the
end of the day post game content much
like the original game the gameplay of
this expansion was tailored to the
specific needs of the story they were
trying to tell one challenged Rockman
and the other designers involved noted
in many interviews was that of finding
new and interesting ways to bond us to
these two characters as they effectively
just have fun goofing around in a mall
with little to no actual conflict water
gun fights brick throwing games and even
goofing around with masks were all added
to the experience we look at contrast a
lot whenever we're in trying to create
pacing of things and you know you can't
have your lights without your darks your
highs without your low so while we're
looking at the Le storyline we also want
to contrast that with what's happening
in the desperation of Joel Additionally
the gameplay in this sequence is very
different to what we experienced through
Joel instead of being a fully grown
Burly man hell-bent on killing anyone
and everyone that threatens his own in
Left Behind or Ellie a young girl and by
virtue of that with a focus on fun and
emphasizing a measured approach it gave
this chapter of the story its own
distinct flavor and so Neil I thought
was the best person for the job in
adapting this complicated tragic and
beautiful story and he was the
camaraderie and Chemistry Between Bella
Ramsey and storm Reed who plays Ellie's
best friend Riley in this episode was
spectacular truly Bella's performance as
Ellie across this season has been stand
out and I'm happy to say it's present in
this episode too witnessing her innocent
amazement when looking at an escalator
for the first time her confusion around
the concept of a photo booth joking that
it was a time machine these are all
perfectly performed and purposeful
editions included by Neil himself to
alleviate the missing interactions
gameplay offered in the DLC and in turn
helped us bond to the characters
themselves during the development of the
game drochman mentions that they had
planned on having more environments to
explore but in the end had to settle for
recycling the same Mall assets for both
the flashback sequences with Riley and
the present-day survival sequences as
she scampages for Joel this is an area
ripe for improvement and this episode
offered a lot more variety in terms of
environments to explore for the first
time outside of the comic book we get to
see the orphanage or boarding school
Ellie resided in prior to the events of
the mainline games it's here we see her
interact with other kids her age as well
as officers who see the potential in
Ellie's abilities establishing the
dormitory she lives in alone and the
isolating and troubling time she had
since royally abruptly left one night
offering up the perfect chance for Riley
herself to once again fall back into
Ellie's life to Kickstart this event
will Adventure it's a story whose events
are hinted at here and there in the game
and are of course what became this DLC
and I really like that this series added
a bunch more of them helping what was
once post-game content fit into and feel
like a Mainline story in episode 1 the
very first scene she takes part in she
shouts I'm not supposed to be here
alluding to the fact that she was never
supposed to leave her fed recorders in
the first place in addition to that a
later scene sees Marlene mention Riley
specifically as someone Ellie should
know and be friendly with but most
notably she mentions her in the past
tense in episode 2 during the
conversation where Ellie asked Joel
whether or not he's killed infected
before she asks the follow-up question
was it hard knowing that they were once
people this is quite obviously inspired
by the tragic fate they both share at
the end of left behind's DLC and
additionally as they're walking along
the highway the response Ellie gives to
the question about a boyfriend is very
telling and of course course finally in
episode 3 Ellie inspects a trapped
infected under a store with the camera
and overall direction focusing
specifically on the eyes and Ellie
examining whether or not there's someone
truly human still in there all of this
was purposely put in place and
truthfully helped to establish Ellie's
backstory within the main story's DNA
without detracting from the pristine
pacing and structure of the original
story itself unfortunately while I love
this episode and everything that it does
I can say that it doesn't feel like it
interrupts the main story drastically
one of the most memorable moments of the
game is the uncertainty of Joel's fate
this section is one of the most tense
and nerve-wracking sequences to play
through also we are emotionally invested
in the fate of Joel following the events
at the University and the game does not
tell us what happens instead Joel Falls
from his horse reminiscent of those old
western films were falling from your
horse usually means death before cutting
to Black and ending the fall chapter on
an emphatic moment in the story what
follows this is a wonderful bit of
misdirection for the first time since
embodying Sarah in the game's opening we
are not in control of Joel but instead
Ellie as she is left to fend for herself
hunting rabbits and eventually deer for
quite some time were left to sit and
Ponder what Joel's fate is until finally
the tension is broken surrounding that
very question much later in the form of
David's chapter which episode 8 later
covers It's a Wonderful piece of
Storytelling and yet as strong as
episode 7 why was its dedication to
unveil Joel immediately utterly ruins
that experience from the game the most
charitable I can be towards this
creative decision is that perhaps
druckman and Mason felt that the
week-long break in between episodes
might achieve the same effect a game did
or somehow spending an entire episode
unsure whether he'd even live would cut
it unfortunately I just don't think it
even remotely lives up to that and even
if they were to move the reveal of
Joel's well-being to the very end of the
episode I'm still not sure that does
anything to address the elephant in the
room you still spend an hour away from
the story for the second time this
season so should it still exist then the
conversations surrounding this very
story whether it be from this DLC or the
second game are some of the most
mind-noming to listen to the sheer
volume of people that called episode 3
quote filler was enough to make me never
want to trust another human being's
opinion on story ever ever again simply
because that story wasn't filler it was
necessary the events of that episode
fundamentally changed Joel Forever
that's precise actually what I mean when
I talk about content being necessary
it's not simply about the necessity to
move the basic story forwards Left
Behind isn't something that does that
it's about enriching what already exists
which in turn elevates events to come
from the outset druckman and Mason's
mission statement has been if we change
something it has to be better and what
this story includes 100 benefits and
improves the base game I mean this is an
episode that explores her sexuality in
ways the prior episodes only sort of
into that it shows us the trauma she
went through with Riley really sells us
on how much she desires to be part of a
potential solution to this outbreak she
doesn't want anyone to have to go
through what she went through and this
naturally reinforces the theme of choice
and that choice being taken away from
her in the final episode of this season
by Joel I think all of that is
phenomenal and obviously an essential
piece of Storytelling that enriches both
this season and the future wants to come
but I don't think copying its precise
location chronologically from The Game's
version works here in the same way that
like I said you don't stop to play Left
Behind mid-story unless you're a
die-hard fan looking for a different
experience it's just not designed to be
seen or received that way by the
audience and I think that's so evident
in its identical placement here in this
version of the story
they heard us
one of the finest aspects of the game's
version of events is that it really
helped Ellie feel distinct to play since
it intercuts between the past story with
Riley and the present with her searching
for medicine while avoiding infected and
bandits it offered up interesting new
ways to play such as that example of
pitting the two enemy types against each
other seeing how Ellie performed based
on what she learned from Joel at this
point could have been an interesting way
to navigate this episode keeping Joel's
fate secret and intercoding between a
new survival objective and these
flashbacks might have been able to
address the feeling of slamming on the
brakes and sucking all tension from the
room I think perhaps I'd have been able
to walk away fondly remembering Ellie's
present sequence of events and the
flashbacks like I did with the DLC
rather than in this episode where the
present amounts to rummaging through a
drawer and one admittedly well-directed
stitching sequence
laughs
I'm not letting you go
ultimately I think they were faced with
a very difficult decision and the
failure to make one that personally
worked for me and many others has meant
much of this review has been focused on
the why of that opinion and I think
that's a shame and it's why so many
people have likewise focused negatively
on this episode instead of looking at
the beauty of it I mean this is an
episode that so perfectly conveys that
teenage feeling of love and not knowing
how to address those feelings properly
particularly when it's a close friend
it's won many LGBT plus viewers have
adored for its accurate portrayal of
their personal struggles in their youth
it's one that captures the childhood Joy
of sneaking out and doing stupid
irresponsible things together it truly
is a real Triumph in isolation and it's
a shame to have to acknowledge it
doesn't quite work in the context of the
episodes it sits between perhaps this is
an episode that would have benefited
from serving as a special between season
1 and 2. similar to its DLC format
perhaps it could have even worked
earlier in the story perhaps it was as
simple as the hunting suggestion I
presented I'm not sure what the answer
is but what I do know is that left
behind is a necessary part of the story
for the last of us but presently it's
not one that can be inserted seamlessly
into the story in either mediums and
that's a huge shame I think I don't want
to give that up
I could just be a poetic and [__] and
lose our minds together
while Left Behind stayed relatively
faithful to its source material this
episode returns to the show's preference
for retooling sequences into a form that
works best for TV rather than a video
game while the game's version of events
begins with Ellie hunting showing her
isolated but determined to face the
terrifying odds surrounding Joel the
show instead immediately introduces the
antagonist of the episode David it's a
small change but one that definitely
establishes a very specific tone from
the outset and sets the ball rolling in
how the episode will ultimately function
by forming an independent plot with
David and his gang to be intercut with
Ellie's own struggles it's clear from
the outset that this will be quite a
different experience the ground is too
cold to dig
will bury your father in the spring this
first scene changes everything because
we now know something about David before
he meets Ellie in the game we as a
player control Ellie as we understand
the situation is dire we have no idea as
the fate of Joel is he alive or dead we
have no idea we don't even know where
she is all we know is that she's
struggling to hunt this deer and once
she successfully fell the deer that's
when we suddenly meet David and his
buddy boy he's diplomatic tries to
de-escalate the situation he's trying to
be as reasonable as he can sure his
demeanor compared to his buddy is
concerning but as he rattles off
possible things he could trade Ellie
exclaims medicine and by doing so tells
us as players that Joel is alive but
struggling it suddenly creates a
situation where who David is is a
question mark but when we now suddenly
meet and when his friend is confused as
to how reasonable David is being for me
it only sold the anticipation more who
is this guy what does he want can we we
trust him and while the adaptation of
this scene is performed spectacularly by
all involved in that episode all of
those questions are either answered
before or we don't even need to ask the
questions in the first place now there
is of course plenty to appreciate in the
scene Troy Baker the voice of Joel Genia
Cameo is a nice touch and so too is the
choice to swap out the bow Ellie had in
the game for a heavy rifle for so long
Ellie has wanted to be self-reliant and
be more like Joel she desperately wants
to be a Survivor and not cargo but
despite the tenacity of this little girl
it's clear what the reality is as she
struggles to hold the very gun she needs
it's a perfect visual metaphor however
because we now know not to trust David
already there's no uncertainty and to be
clear I don't think that is necessarily
good or bad it's just an observation in
fact there's plenty to love about this
change and the performance in this scene
we understand more clearly Who David is
and as Ellie continues to act tough self
assured in putting up this facade we can
see David the master manipulator and
narcissist see right through this thinly
veiled facade this creates a different
kind of anticipation and definitely a
lot of dread despite Ellie holding this
rifle it feels like David is in control
of all things and that's a wonderful
change what I do have an issue with
however is what happens or should I say
doesn't happen next in the game while
definitely wait for his partner to
retrieve the medicine for the trade the
infected begin to swarm the area
resulting in another survival situation
one where you no longer can feel
uncertain about David you need to trust
him and trust him you absolutely do
together you two cooperate and through
that shared experience he becomes
someone that seems more trustworthy than
he actually is which makes what happens
later all the more striking you see
everything happens for a reason
the TV show manages thankfully to have
plenty of faithful and striking scenes
later with David but they entirely
removed the infected from the equation
and I've bit my tongue on this for quite
a while now but I think it's time to
address the big fungal elephant in the
room the sheer lack of any noteworthy
infected in the back half of this season
from the outset I want to be clear that
I don't think every episode needs to
have infected in fact I think it's
better that not every episode does and
the core of the last of us is very much
Joel and Ellie's relationship in this
infected world as I pointed out I
especially love that episode 3 took an
entirely different direction from the
infected bloodsports of the game and
gave us a more grounded and human story
with Bill and Frank but when you think
about the last of us it's difficult not
to also think about the infected you
play against they are a core pillar of
this game and furthermore the story
needs them so to help me better
understand Craig Basin had this to say
on the removal of that scene with David
and the infected because at the end of
the day it is a scene that they removed
from the game that does do a lot of
heavy lifting in terms of Storytelling
David is carefully creating a
circumstance whereby Ellie will lean
forward he's not gonna pull her he's
going to make her want to lean forward
in the game that discussion happens
after Ellie and David have to fight a
lot of infected teeth so they're bonded
by a certain trust at because of
gameplay while we could do that the
flawed implications of a lot of infected
running around out there that can just
get you at any moment it would permeate
throughout the episode and we wanted to
function a different way
I think this is a perfectly reasonable
point and when they clearly thought long
and hard about and I'll even concede
that with this current iteration of the
David character the dynamic between
himself and Ellie might feel strange
with David no longer being shrouded in
mystery during this encounter so I think
there are plenty of good reasons to have
gone in the direction they did but I
still have a problem with it personally
the back half of this season where
things start to get dire in the game
where we face more and more infected
more tribulations on our way to meet
with the fireflies every encounter every
kill every single time you have to avoid
the infected it's another reminder of
how sick and destroyed this world is
that they inhabit it reminds us why
mankind is so overwhelmed by the
infected and most importantly it
reinforces Ellie's why her reason for
going on this Mission she wants to go to
the fireflies to save everyone from the
infected so no one has to go through
what she did with Riley ever again it's
simple but it makes sense HBO's The Last
of Us does a great job at establishing
that very threat of the infected early
on and even provide reasonable
explanations as to why there are fewer
in the wilderness this all makes perfect
sense and I understand wanting to go
with a more grounded approach I won't
dispute that but I must say as a fan of
the last of us since 2012 when I first
saw the trailer back half of this season
is disappointingly light on that
infected aspect and while I understand
the infective felt like a massive part
of the games because they were a primary
enemy we fought and played against with
little direct involvement to the story
they still created the atmosphere that
was this game and in the second half I
especially started to feel like
something was missing and honestly even
in retrospect I still do I do however
have hope for future seasons and that
hope comes from rising tension while the
first game has plenty of infected action
and grotesque moments of horror it is
still one single game a complete
experience produced to completion
without any consideration for what may
or may not come afterwards it was as I
said a complete experience that did not
need to build to anything and one wanted
to tell the story with nothing held back
HBO's TV series on the other hand does
need to build to something more as seen
in pretty much every single episode I
spoke on in this video there are Easter
eggs and pieces of exposition that point
directly to the coming Seasons season 1
of The Last of Us isn't a complete
experience it is the first of what will
be I assume many more seasons because of
this one could argue that it makes sense
to not go all out with the infected
Madness right away and instead use this
season to introduce us to this force of
disaster ride Julie how were people
infected what are clickers and how do
they communicate what is a bloater
dotted throughout this season while
hindering the significance of Ellie's
Journey for me and dampening the
atmosphere of the story I can in a way
see the utility in not going all out
from the get-go we are building to a
crescendo here and that Crescendo isn't
in season one
wake the [__] up Joe if anybody makes it
down here you [__] killed them you
got it for me the differences from this
point on are brilliant and even when one
particular moment remains super faithful
to the games it gave me a greater
appreciation for other changes that were
made in the past to enhance the
significance impact and implications of
that very moment an aspect of this
episode that feels distinct and
different is that of the perspective
this very much feels like Ellie's
episode and her Story the game had a
switching to and fro between Joel and
Elliot until the end and though that
created an anticipation for Joel to come
in save the day and rescue Ellie only
for the game to subvert that entirely
and have Ellie defeat David herself and
while the TV show does achieve that same
desired effect with us as audience
members anticipating Pedro's Joel to
somehow arrive to save Ellie from David
this feels very much like Bella Ramsay's
moment to shine and take Center Stage
tell them that Ellie he's a little girl
who broke her [__] finger
finger I think I'd be remiss for not
mentioning at least once Scott Shepard's
intensely unsettling performances David
while I had my criticisms for what that
opening scene took away from what I was
used to seeing in this section I must
say what it offered in terms of
exposition and context for the character
was incredible he's a delusional power
hungry Tyrant a disgusting monstrous
human being that preys on those that are
too weak to fight back and defend
themselves and every ounce of that comes
through in this performance and what's
more is this scene offers a new line
that honestly is quite Illuminating he
says Ellie has a quote violent heart
we've seen Ellie show admiration for the
violent acts Joel commits on her behalf
we've seen how she's physically lashed
out when she was first bit in that last
episode's flashback with Riley we all
have different sides to ourselves this
is undoubtedly true but it takes a truly
violent person like David to see that
part of Ellie for what it is so quickly
and unfortunately for David he doesn't
know the half of it despite the focus on
La there is still a close eye being Joel
while staying true to its more grounded
nature compared to the video game this
version of Joel while he doesn't mow
through dozens of enemies to get to
Ellie he does manage to assassinate
someone while at 10 and we even get to
see the scene where he tortures folks to
tell him which way to go it's all
terrific stuff but as I said the real
star of this episode and this
centerpiece of this story is Ellie and
her inevitable entanglement with David
you don't know how good I am
you don't know what I could have given
you it's exceptionally difficult to
conjure the same level of tension
emotion and Dread a well-conceived video
game can deliver and The Last of Us is
as premium of an experience as one could
hope to enjoy in video game format as I
mentioned the game places Us in Ellie's
tenacious but small shoes as she engages
with and tries to survive against easily
the most horrific human Encounter of the
series David is a disgusting
manipulative narcissistic murderous
creep of a man who is pursuing Ellie
keeping her alive all because he simply
wants her it's a terrifying concept on
its own but once you add cannibalism and
the desperation these people are in into
the mix everything gets that much more
terrifying we aren't controlling Joel
we're simply anticipating him as we
crawl around corners avoiding shards of
glass that might alert David to her
whereabouts all of it very much feels
like a little girl trying to escape a
monster and quite honestly the first
time I played this encounter while not
being particularly difficult with the
control I had on top of all the layers
of complexity this encounter brings with
it I knew this was going to be a near
impossible level to beat in the show but
damn it they just might have done it
this moment hit me like a train I've
spent a large amount of time in this
video discussing the benefits and
mediums such as video games has offered
the story of The Last of Us however it's
this scene that I think shines a light
on and acts as a prime example of one
advantage in this case live action has
over video games the atmosphere
appropriate for a game is very different
to that of a live action TV series and
the reason for that has everything to do
with the different thresholds each
medium requires to suspend the audiences
or players disbelief in order to feel
tension in a given scene the writers
animators and or directors need to take
the appropriate measures to ensure they
don't under or overstep when it comes to
playing with an audience's disbelief we
need to believe that what's happening
before us is congruent with the material
of the story there are ways around this
but depending on the medium you've
chosen to tell your story in it may
require you to take things any more
extreme or muted Direction I wrote a
video a while back about Disney's recent
obsession with reimagining all their
classic animated films as quote live
action for the new generations and if
there's anything that's apparent after
having watched the live action Lion King
is that without the flexibility of
Animation the characters in The Lion
King look emotionless stripped of all
expression joy and color that the
original enjoyed and my point is when it
comes to watching animation the audience
is far more forgiving and accepting of
the zany and the unconventional you'll
believe a lion cub can talk can live on
delicious looking bugs and be friends
with the unlikely Duo of a warthog and
meerkat whereas in live action we have
an entirely different set of
expectations that we more specifically
map onto our own real lived experiences
in other words we expect live action to
work and behave like well the real world
now this might sound like I'm pointing
out yet again another massive
disadvantage of live action compared to
animation and in the case of the Lion
King who decided to adapt a story that
was designed with animation in mind it
is but if you take a realistic story
like the last of us and make the correct
subtlety changes to translate it to live
action you grant yourself the ability to
utilize the realism of the live-action
medium to draw out some of the most
insane emotional responses from your
audience but it needs to be done right
and HBO is The Last of Us did it right
because video games require gameplay to
advance the story and to well be a game
Neil drockman needed to rely on that
aspect of the medium to advance Joel and
Ellie's budding relationship and bond us
to the pairing themselves and it worked
fantastically well because Joe is the
character we control for the majority of
the game anytime Ellie helps us achieve
a task reach a spot or saves us from an
enemy we grow closer and in the process
Thunder of her we chat with her we walk
with her and we listen to her tell bad
jokes this approach is so effective that
once we actually play with Joel and
she's not around or even in some
instances where she is not acting like
herself we feel that as a player and
miss her the TV show naturally can't
achieve this same effect and so decided
to lean in a different direction is
instead of Ellie demonstrating how
helpful she can be in a pinch during
combat the TV show decided to save
Ellie's first kills for one specific
scene
[Applause]
this scene this performance this
reaction she gives afterwards it's
breathtakingly tragic and as a viewer
one that knew exactly what was coming
this scene made me cry when the video
game did not and I think that has
everything to do with the show owner's
choice to keep Ellie's hands largely
clean all throughout this story there's
a moment in the game where Ellie saves
Joel's Life by killing an assailant the
TV show allows Ellie to save Joel but
not kill the assailant a small
difference but one that made the world
of difference to her character in this
moment this is how you leverage the
strengths of your medium and another
small detail that further adds to the
feeling that this is Ellie's episode is
Joel doesn't arrive to stop her
mid-assault he doesn't stop her from
attacking David's lifeless corpse
instead she leaves the scenario scared
out of her mind half petrified half
disassociated and on the verge of a
total mental break and that's Joel steps
in
it's okay baby girl
this is Joel Miller the concerned loving
father trying to comfort his adopted
younger daughter he tried his best to
reach her to Shield her from the evils
of this horrible infected sick world but
he was ultimately unable to the guardian
has failed but it's not too late for him
to succeed as a father and in the
process of holding her giving her that
security blanket he manages to on some
level save her emotionally the contrast
of the blood splattered against the
snowy background is incredibly striking
but what struck out to me most in this
scene was a collection of words uttered
by Joel to Ellie baby girl remind you of
anything come on baby girl I gotta get
you come on
come on
come on baby
this is what Ellie means to Joel he
failed to protect her but did manage to
save her and from this moment on God
help any [__] stand in his way
[Music]
in the games Ellie's mother isn't
present or even flashed back too instead
she's represented or defined by a single
note she left behind for Ellie and of
course her switchblade which Ellie
carries with her at all times and that
makes it all the more interesting that
this scene exists in the first place
according to Neil druckman following
production of the game he was approached
to work on an animated short and for
that very project he had written a brief
story about Ellie's mother however it
never made it past the writing phase
until today the scene that was written
and subsequently adapted into this
episode's opening demonstrates the
circumstances surrounding Ellie's birth
and her mother's inevitable demise in
the final podcast discussed in the first
season Craig Basin goes into great
detail about why he liked this scene so
much and the significance it had within
the story and honestly it was quite
Illuminating he explains that A Moment
Like childbirth which is so typically
joyous and congratulatory is now instead
soaked in sadness as he puts it the
performance by Ashley Johnson the
original voice of belly as her mother
offers the scene this incredible passing
of the torch type feeling on this new
iteration of the character and on so
many levels this is just gorgeous and
once again just like Joel has
consistently failed Ellie on his journey
across America with her the first person
Ellie is bonded to at the very beginning
of her life fails her and is forced to
abandon her right away soaked in sadness
as Craig Mason describes it it is a
perfect collection of words to convey
the vibe of this scene in question and I
adored the logic behind the decision to
have this scene appear here on episode
9's beginning and not in say episode 2.
had the scene appeared in a more
conventional space like episode 2 it
would have taken away more from the
story than you might have realized for
this season of The Last of Us to
function as the game did it's important
for us that we are bonded with Joel yes
but it's also important that we see the
world through his eyes just like the
game through the story we investigate
and come to learn about the extended
cast and indeed our co-main character
through Joel discovering more about
Ellie in other words it was important
that we as an audience were offer of
that same experience as the game that
same journey and had we been given that
level of exposition and insight into
Ellie's character so early on it could
have spoiled that atmosphere that feels
so true to the games for us to suddenly
have some fundamental understanding of
Ellie that Joel doesn't have it creates
a disconnect and placing it here in the
final episode offers all the benefits of
putting in anywhere else with none of
the downsides
[Music]
Furthermore with Marlene playing such a
pivotal role in this scene it has a
certain thematic relevance to the
conclusion of the story also reframing
certain things to once again enhance our
experiences Marlene represents the
diametric opposite to Joel in terms of
philosophy when it comes to Ellie and
her immunity they've both accepted this
kid in their own ways Marlene is a
passive mother from afar following her
biological mother's demise and Joel her
de facto parental figure or father today
both of them shared the desire to
protect Ellie but there are fundamental
differences as to why they do that as
they again point out on the podcast
Marlene's love encompasses all of
humanity and what she will do
specifically for the greater good of the
world she's a freedom fighter at the end
of the day and willing to give up her
life to achieve those goals she's
willing to compromise her morals if it
means the success of the Firefly's
mission in other words Marlene at this
moment in time cares for Ellie now
because of what she means to the world
whereas on the other side of things Joel
wants to save her because of what she
means to him he doesn't know the rest of
the world he knows he cares about her
and values her life and safety Above All
Else and having that Dynamic brought to
the Forefront in this way was so
striking I felt It's a Wonderful
explanation for her immunity and
resonated so perfectly with this
episode's impending subject matter
Ellie
what
I found this in there Beefaroni Chef
Boyardee
oh cool I love this part of the series
for the same reason I love this part of
the game feeding this way towards a
character and the relationship with
another is rare but in video games I'd
argue it's even more rare and I think
naughty dog really outdid themselves
when it came to bringing this sequence
to life for Ellie and Joel in the first
game it hurts it hurts to hear see and
feel Joel who was once so closed off and
Ellie who was once so open and chatty
now finding themselves with their roles
reversed following the harrowing
situation they both narrowly survived
thanks entirely to Ellie's determination
to survive and in the games this is
almost more apparent though I will say
the show does a phenomenal job at
adapting it as best they can in the
games we've come to rely on Ellie for
some snacky commentary and more directly
we need her in order to progress through
the game and there's this moment where
we Joel need Ellie to boost onto this
ledge and drop down a ladder we walk up
to the ledge press the action button the
same way we have done an infinite number
of times in this playthrough up until
now and not
Ellie doesn't respond and while the TV
recreates a very similar moment here
which I love as I knighted the gameplay
I think it does lose just a little
something that jarring feeling of a
mechanical Norm banishing is a moment
unique to video games and man did I feel
that when I played it something I've
heard mentioned to me a couple of times
was this section leading up to and
during the famous giraffe segment
possessing strange pacing as if it was
rushing to the next sequence and while I
can't say that was my experience I will
say their observations may be very well
valid but I also think there was nothing
the TV show could have done to remedy
that issue for them the reason being is
this section of the game they're
adapting doesn't have any enemies it's
an open area and even when you get to
more narrow sections leading up to and
during the giraffe segment it's designed
from the ground up to be played at the
player's unique Pace it's at their
discretion you can sit and listen to
Ellie for as long as you want explore as
much as you want watch and enjoy the
giraffes with her for as long as you you
want before moving on and the TV show
just can't do that what I can do however
is go above and beyond in actually using
a real life giraffe for that moment and
I honestly love that aspect of it but
moreover I think my favorite part of
that moment was Joel's reaction he
doesn't focus on the giant beautiful
animal coming closer instead his
attention is squarely on Ellie watching
her smile and for the very first time in
a while just have fun which perfectly
brings out his concerns for her he asks
if she's sure that she wants to go
through with all of this and to that she
says
it can't be for nothing
this is Ellie convicted in achieving her
goal of making her life matter making
all the sacrifices and death mean
something in the end and once again
reinforces the complexity of what
ultimately happens God I love this
episode it's brilliant I've spoken at
length over the course of this video
praising the various actions and
portrayals of these iconic characters
both from a performance and writing
standpoint and while I stand by all of
that praise I'd like to for a moment
share a concern I have with regards to
Joel's depiction in the series and why
I'm worried for what it might mean in
the future it was me
I was the guy who shot and missed this
this is a lovely scene and one that has
resonated with many people for obvious
reasons so take this as a concern rather
than a criticism to acknowledge let me
explain for me when it comes to
character writing it's less about what a
character says and more about what a
character actually means and does that
matters and bonds me to them when a
character comes out and explicitly tells
us how they are feeling and what they
want it suddenly becomes less
interesting than the alternative and
that alternative is subtext the last of
us as a video game series is filled with
subtext it's the best part of the
writing for me I think with Joel never
outwardly or explicitly addressing
certain sensitive areas of his past and
his feelings because he simply isn't
comfortable with himself or equipped to
express those feelings and so instead we
look at his actions to communicate how
he feels about Ellie his demeanor his
willingness to communicate and
eventually help even his willingness to
tell bad jokes it informs us that he
loves her and it's because Joel's law of
language isn't explicitly staining how
he feels very often I think that makes
him feel all the more human and moreover
made a key moment in the next game the
sequel that much more powerful I'm going
to be talking about the second game and
ultimately the material that will be
covered in the second and third Seasons
most likely so if you'd like to remain
spoiler free of that material feel free
to use the chapters on the progress bar
down below to skip to the next
spoiler-free part
our future Days
days of you and me
[Music]
there you go
this is my second favorite scene in the
entire game it's so beautiful this is
the most explicit and honest Joel has
ever been with Ellie about what she
means to him and he's doing it not
through telling her how he feels but
instead through singing it to her and
even as he's doing so you can see his
nerves his voice is almost shaking it's
a stunningly perfect and vulnerable
performance and I just don't think if
this scene were to be recreated by HBO
that it would feel as emotionally
powerful and it has everything to do
with respecting subtext HBO's adaptation
of Joel has been terrific Pedro looks
the part he feels the part and he even
sounds the part he's got a wonderful
combination of a tough and warm exterior
that is so difficult to pull off
Faithfully this is to say that my issue
with this version of Joel stems from the
scripting itself there's a beautifully
touching and raw set of scenes in the
story that are some of my favorites in
isolation but again I fear for what that
might mean for the story moving forward
these are scenes that otherwise happened
off-screen or outright never happened at
all and those scenes in question are
Joel's breakdown in front of Tommy once
he gets to Jackson and his eventual
confession to Ellie about his suicide
attempt paired with how much she means
to him again these scenes are utterly
brilliant on their own if not a little
on the nose in certain parts but okay
we'll put that to the side and it's not
like what he says in these scenes aren't
true to how the character of Joel might
feel either I just don't think the
original character would Express himself
like this at all we know what Ellie
means to Joel we know how badly he
needed time to take her and we know the
reasons he had for feeling like he
needed to let go and we understood all
of that through subtext there are of
course positives to be taken from this
narrative route I've spoken at length in
this video already singing their praises
but with these scenes as they are with
these dialogue exchanges right now I'm
worried the result for season 2 will be
lesser without them because my favorite
scene in part 2 is actually one of the
very last in the game one that finally
gives us closure for the relationship
we've been so heavily invested in
throughout this series and it depends on
Joel being a specific way up until then
in part two we see Joel step into
physical altercations on Ellie's behalf
and this fits his love language
perfectly we even get glimpses into the
extra effort he's going to to reach out
to Ellie in any meaningful way he can
things like learning jokes that he
otherwise never would or reading her
favorite comic books that he definitely
never would all of this occurs with a
painfully tense atmosphere that he's not
addressing until she does for him
halfway through and that doesn't go well
and he just gets angry these attempts at
reconnection feel almost embarrassing
and it hurts to watch it's brilliant
this is all to say that the scene they
share at the end of the game feels that
much more powerful because he actually
opens up and speaks in no uncertain
terms for the very first time to her
face somehow the lord gave me a second
chance at that moment
I would do it all over again
when this scene ended with Ellie giving
him a second chance in Joel saying I'd
like that I was left as a shell of a
human being I couldn't pick up that game
again to play until I started writing
this video it impacted me that much I
was a wreck and so with material that
had that sort of impact on me I can't
say it could ever hope to be as
impactful at least not in that same way
with the current more open incarnation
of the Joel character what made this
scene so intensely powerful was how
closed off Joel was up until then and
while the HBO version is clearly still
somewhat closed off he's nowhere near as
such compared to the game and as a
result I hope they take these scenes in
a slightly different direction because
my worry is if they play it straight it
will leave fans feeling like it didn't
hit as hard as it could have at least
that's my opinion
find someone else there is no one else
when this sequence began I was extremely
curious to see the direction they take
it with because again so much of what
makes this a brilliant sequence to play
through is the fact that you get to play
through it you're forced to take out
these folks and be as aggressive as you
want with the mandatory kill that will
lock in the events that will unfold
thereafter and uh fun fact when I play
games like this my inclination is to
always hoard as many resources as
possible because who knows when I'll be
able to get more later this normally
translates into me ending these sorts of
games with some of the most powerful
Weaponry available to me being the only
ones that are available to me with ammo
in the last of us one of the most
imposing enemy types is that of the
bloser and fire is extremely effective
against them I don't like where this is
going because of this I would literally
never use my flamethrower outside of a
bloater encounter and so you might see
where I'm going with this when I played
through this game for the very first
time by the time that I got to the
operating room with the doctor and
nurses after having stormed this
building guns blazing I was left
standing there contemplating the
morality of this decision with my only
weapon remaining being the flamethrower
so despite me being on the fence about
the whole thing at the time I had no
other choice than to brutally burn all
of these people to death in the most
painful fashion thankfully the show did
take that route and instead decided to
Anchor this in Pedro Pascal's
performance and it's absolutely haunting
as the main theme of the show playing in
a very dark and sad Arrangement Joel
walks an almost Death March completely
disassociated on his face taking out
anyone and everyone that he sees in his
way the best kill of them all being the
completely deadpan dispassionate and
almost haphazard murder of the doctor
it's performed to utter perfection
can't keep her safe forever
this was a moment I honestly forgot
about or at the very least didn't fully
appreciate the significance of in the
game when I first played through it but
in reality it's the perfect ending to
Joel's Journey as a character and I
think the TV show emphasized that in a
wonderful way the character-defining
incident that makes Joel who he is in
this series is the death of his daughter
Sarah and throughout this journey across
America we've seen him apprehensively
and gradually regain his Humanity piece
by piece Ellie has made Joel feel like a
human being again one that values what
tomorrow can offer and doesn't just
exist as a rough angry shell of a man
those demons from his ultimate failure
as a father still very much haunt him
see not just in that moment where he
takes out the federal agent but
additionally in various scenes where he
starts to suffer the effects of what
appears to be PTSD he's outwardly
expressed that he feels like a failure
for not living up to what he believes he
should be for both Sarah and now Ellie
failing to protect her against the
horrors of this world and now in this
parking garage ho holding what is now
effectively his daughter he once again
finds himself staring down the barrel of
a gun threatening her very life and he's
not gonna fail this time
the decisions Joel makes in these scenes
are ones that have been the subject of
discourse for over a decade and it's one
of the most defining aspects of the
entire plot was this the right decision
and while there have been countless
videos discussing the ins and outs of it
that's not something I want to draw a
definitive conclusion on here heck it's
not something druckman himself draws a
definitive conclusion on either during
testing the audience was split some
people were concerned with whether the
fireflies could have even done it some
argued that didn't matter and that it's
simply about the fact Joel believed it
and almost everyone was unanimous in
that he took Ellie's agency away but
what was most evident was that when
asking an audience of parents every
single one cited with Joe and I think
that's the genius of this ending it's
about perspective it's the perfect
conclusion to a story where everyone
thinks they're doing the right thing
because of their lived experiences and
that's a perfect setup If Ever I did see
one for what's to come in season 2 and
Beyond as the pair make their Ascent up
towards Jackson there's a real sense of
unease in the air attention Rising as to
whether Ellie truly believes the story
Joel spun in the car Journey on their
way to this point she entertains his
ramblings as he speaks with total
openness about Sarah drawing comparisons
there and behaving in a way that conveys
the idea that a huge weight has suddenly
been lifted off of his shoulders but
Ellie's the opposite and we're soon
faced with a question that will Echo for
Seasons to come swear to me
swear to me that everything you said
about the fireflies is true it's a
Monumental moment for the two and it's
heartbreaking to see Joel tell Ellie
such a bold-faced lie druckman and Mason
seem unanimous on at least one aspect of
this ending however it's that it's not
so much about whether Ellie truly
believes him or not it's that she needs
to believe him but the idea that such an
important figure in her life would do
something like that is a thought that is
impossible to stomach and what a way to
end a season to go forward thinking
about how that decision will affect the
relationship to think about how Joel's
choice will affect them both
and the World At Large
and is made evident by this frequently
long video I've had a million things to
say about this series and even as I
write this I still find myself in awe of
what this team managed to accomplish
from a writing directorial artistic and
even logical perspective 99 times out of
100 a property like this would have
ended up like all the rest unimpressive
emotionally vapid soulless cash grabs
with no respect for the source material
adding yet another legendary name to the
pile of terrible video game adaptations
to say that this project and its success
was a miracle is putting it mildly and
to say that I'm excited for what season
2 has to offer is as a large and
understatement as I am capable of
conveying and so with season 1 a
resounding success now breaking the
cycle of bad live-action video game
adaptations and producing a real labor
of love capturing the hearts and minds
of long time and new fans alike I
politely ask Mr Mason and Mr druckman to
swear to me to keep this incredible
energy up as we head into the immensely
challenging part two
okay
[Music]
foreign